Yup.
Hey,
every buddy,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by Lumosity.
Lumosity is essentially a gym for your brain.
Uh,
the idea behind that Lumosity is give your brain some exercise just like you
give your body some exercise and do it in a way that's actually fun,
fun and interesting.
It's their brain games.
Um,
Lumosity is essentially without the way they've set it up.
you can go to Lumosity and enter in a bunch of different parameters what you're
interested in doing,
working on different things like memory or what have you,
uh,
challenging your brain with scientifically designed training.
And if you click the get started now button,
you see what I'm talking about.
They have all these different aspects that you can,
a,
you could work on specifically like memory,
recalling the locations of things,
uh,
learning new subjects quickly.
Attention is another one.
Speed flexibilities one.
I really like avoiding errors,
multitasking quickly and efficiently.
And then once you enter in all your parameters,
they set up these challenging games for you that are actually fun.
They're fun in their exercise essentially for your brain.
Lumosity is brain games are designed by top scientists to train the mental
processes,
and over time you can track your progress online and compare yourself with other
people.
So it's essentially,
look,
we all like playing stupid games.
What do you like playing?
What?
Let's set candy,
stupid fucking candy game.
The kids play candy crush or angry birds,
whatever it is.
Those are wastes of time.
Waits is of time.
Notice something.
My vocabulary.
It's quite excellent.
Waste to CIS of time.
I'm Gollum.
It loves it.
Um,
but Lumosity allows you to do it and actually do something good for yourself.
Get your brain moving,
get it,
get it exercising just a few minutes a day.
You can play from anywhere you computer,
iPad,
or iPhone with the fleet,
the flea,
no free Lumosity APP.
Have Fun.
Workout your brain and make Lumosity part of your everyday routine.
Check out my special Lumosity page.
To get started,
go to lumosity.com/joe lumosity.com/joe.
Click the start training button and start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe.
We're also brought to you by audible.com audible.com is the internet.
The Internet's number one provider of audio entertainment.
They have hundreds of thousands,
at least 800,000 titles,
uh,
more than a hundred thousand titles,
books,
podcasts,
comedy.
They have literally everything you would ever want as far as audio
entertainment.
I'm a huge fan of audible.
It's a fantastic service.
It's been around for a long time.
They've always actually even supported standup.
There was quite a while ago,
Steve Marmel,
a couple other guys were doing a five new minutes every week and uploading them
on audible.com.
It was a kind of interesting little experiment that they were doing.
And um,
they,
they have comedy specials,
they have radio shows,
they have,
um,
old speeches and lectures.
It's just a,
a veritable feast of audio entertainment and an awesome treasure chest of audio
entertainment.
And if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book in 30 free days of audible service.
That's audible.com forward slash Joe.
Um,
I couldn't say enough about audible.
Really love it.
Largest selection of audio books online over 150,000.
Exactly.
Uh,
you can also use,
use them from your smartphone,
tablet,
desktop,
and they have a thing for the,
um,
the Amazon kindle fire HD called whisper whisper sync.
It's an application that is truly brilliant and what it does is allows you to
read a book,
uh,
from Your Amazon,
those,
you know,
those uh,
kindle fires.
So like just like sort of an iPad for reading books,
kindle fire,
HD movies on it and shit like that.
But this application allows you to download one of the audible books.
You read up into a certain point and then when you're done reading,
you get in your car and the,
the audio version of it,
the audible version of it starts playing and direct sync.
That's Campbell Mclaren.
If you hear that guy was sucking into the microphone lookers coffee,
I didn't.
audible.com forward slash was on.
Oh,
of course it was.
You don't hear yourself and your own ears have there.
Yeah.
audible.com forward slash joke,
get an audible book and go check that shit out.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain shroom tech,
new mood.
Audible is not what I'm talking about.
Alpha brain,
what on it.com is a human optimization website.
What we have is things that make your body work better,
things that make your brain work better,
athletic equipment that enhances your physical strength and conditioning and
stuff that you can use.
That really does apply to a athletics.
We sell a lot of cardio equipment as far as like we sell battle ropes and weight
vests and strength and conditioning equipment like kettlebells and maces and
steel clubs and medicine balls.
We essentially sell things that we use for strength and conditioning,
whether it's martial arts training or people that do any real rigorous activity
that requires you to have physical strength.
Um,
there's no better way than,
than using things like kettlebells that use your whole body as one unit.
Um,
if you are thinking about doing it,
um,
please get a trainer or at the very least,
watch some instructional videos and start out slow with some lightweights and
use proper form.
Don't want to hurt yourself.
Uh,
we,
we sell a bunch of foods.
We sell a hemp force protein and hemp force bars,
which are excellent and nutritious alternatives to shitty snack foods that you
might have laying around your office.
And,
um,
lots of other things like,
buffalo bars,
these Tonka,
uh,
buffalo bars,
which are made the same way the,
uh,
American Indians used to make them.
They're,
they're made with cranberries actually there.
They're quite delicious,
uh,
traditional 100% natural Lakota tribal recipe,
really good stuff.
And they stay sit a stable on your shelf for up to 18 months.
And this is,
you know,
doing it the way native Americans do it.
So you can pretend you're an Indian out there wandering your woods.
Pretend you're eating your tonka bar from a Tonka,
you'll kill yourself.
Does that racist?
And to make an Indian accent,
I'm not sure.
Anyway,
go down a Japanese to me.
So I think you're okay.
There was a little Japanese,
Very Samurai,
right?
Uh,
on a.com.
N N I t use the Codeword Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements,
all kinds of groovy shit there.
Um,
as far as health and supplements for conditioning and your immune system and all
sorts of good shit.
And have you used the Codeword Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
The guy who hired me for UFC 12 is here,
ladies and gentlemen,
cue the music.
Young Jamie Tuh Tuh Tuh Tuh
[inaudible]
experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Once upon a time I met a man named Campbell Mclaren who dragged me into a world
of mixed martial arts.
Wonderful.
Dragged you.
Pulled me in buddy.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
I was in Los Angeles and I got a call from my manager and it was essentially
saying,
all right,
there's this thing that we've got an offer before.
I'm sure you're not going to want to do this,
but next friend Jeff says,
what a pitch mine as well.
And now here we are many,
many years later.
Um,
that was UFC 12 in 1997.
Uh,
and um,
Bob Meyrowitz was the president and owner of needs.
You just give him the finger.
How dare you cause that what that was now it was picking my Bob Myerwitz was the
uh,
the owner and a Campbell Mclaren.
What was your official title?
Oh,
Kylie's exec producer,
you know,
co creators.
What they call me now?
Aye.
He peed the shows and was uh,
the head of programming for the companies.
And you were there for you fc one that was there for 0.01 young guy was,
oh my boy.
I was like a little,
see my up there on the screen.
Also scrappy little youngster when I was working for you guys.
What happened?
I became an old man.
No,
you can gain years and uh,
you know you still can look oh gay.
Cause you look like a fighter to me.
You look more like a fight or now than when you started.
Well I didn't lift weights done.
That's why I started doing Jujitsu.
Like right before I did that show.
But back then I was just doing kickboxing.
No,
no weightlifting ever.
But once I started June doing Jujitsu and getting manhandled,
I said to put some meat on you guys.
This is ridiculous.
I'm tired of getting raped.
Well,
the Gracies,
here's the pledge they made to me.
Then you'd go,
you know,
gamble gum,
started Brazilian Jujitsu,
Gracie Jujitsu with the family.
We promise not to break your ribs the first couple times.
That was the price.
That's it.
That's the,
that's what I get from nobody writes on three.
Yeah.
You don't get good at Jujitsu by not getting your ass kicked.
Everybody gets their ass kicked.
It's impossible to not get your ass kicked and get good at Jujitsu.
You have to do it.
You have to experience it.
Do you think you're good at Jujitsu?
I got a couple of black belts.
As far as like regular people.
Yeah,
I'm good.
As far as like really good.
You get to people.
I'm not that good.
So say you were going to fight like a guy like a guy named Wesley snipes.
Campbell's other idea.
Oh,
I'm so sorry that didn't happen.
God,
that would've been great.
I changed my whole life for like four months.
Oh,
that was hard.
He changed his life too.
But yeah,
unfortunately he changed,
but we found out why he wanted to do it in the first place when all the tax
stuff came out.
But Campbell called me up and uh,
asked me out of the blue if I wanted to fight Wesley snipes.
I tell anything.
I thought thought about it very long.
I don't remember how long I thought about it.
I think you came directly to my house and you didn't even,
you dropped the phone and ran to my house to sign the contract.
I mean,
no,
you were very into it.
There was no doubt about it.
Well,
I just didn't imagine that a guy who's never done Jujitsu and his life was going
to keep me from strangling them.
I'm like,
okay,
like what are you,
what are you going to do?
You're going to get good in a couple of months.
Do you know,
you think there's anyone out there now that still thinks that still thinks they
can do?
The people who have never trained this is that simple.
Anybody who's ever trained,
you just do it all.
You feel so helpless.
I,
when I go into Jujitsu,
I was 26 years old.
I was a black belt in taekwondo,
former us open champion,
very good athlete.
Kickbox my whole life was constantly working out.
It was very lean,
very in shape.
And I just got ragdolled.
I mean ragdolled we're like,
Gee,
guys would just do whatever they wanted.
To me.
It was so humiliating.
It was so like enlightening too though.
Like Sergio Colon,
I don't know if you remember Sergio Colon,
he was one of Carlson Gracie's guys and um,
John Awano who makes them want Ogeez now.
Um,
I,
I can't,
that's where I first started to some Gracie's and I took a class one class only
at Hickson's and then I went from Hickson's and uh,
I guess it was 97,
96,
maybe 96.
I went from,
yeah,
it was 96 in Hickson's and Carlson Gracie's and then 98 from the 98 on,
I've been with the Machados.
So,
um,
when I started training with them,
it was just immediately apparent that I had these delusions in my head.
Like these,
the same thing that I like the first feeling I got when I saw UFC too.
I've watched it on video tape.
I got it from Hollywood,
bought one of those Hollywood video stores.
And um,
I remember thinking right away,
shit,
um,
I got fucking learn this.
Like this is this guy in who knows how to do something that none of these people
know how to do.
And it was a real,
like a,
like a disturbing awakening watching hoists,
strangle all these people like,
okay,
would he's,
you know,
this ain't a coincidence.
He keeps doing that.
Like nobody could stop him from doing that.
Like,
oh,
I got to learn that shit.
And when I actually did start training it,
it was so shocking.
Like I was so far off from what I thought I was going to be able to do.
I thought I'd be able to keep,
keep say,
you know,
stay safe.
I go,
Eh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm pretty good athlete.
Most of these people don't know what they're doing.
I've been in martial arts my whole life,
helpless,
helpless on the ground,
just helpless.
And I wrestled.
I wrestled a year in high school is a decent wrestler,
helpless,
getting strangled,
triangled arm barred.
If you don't train,
if you don't go in there and don't train with like really elite Jujitsu people,
you really don't know,
help us.
You are,
you don't know.
You got these ideas in your head and I think that's probably what was going on
with Wesley.
Probably had these ideas based on his karate background.
And so these ideas about what he was going to be capable of doing.
Um,
yeah.
Or maybe you thought he could use a sword because yep.
People kept saying just play and get to use the plate when his vampire strength
too.
That's a lot,
a lot of advantages to being bored.
You know,
I told you,
I saw
that video that he sent,
he was training in Kenya somewhere in it.
Maybe it was South Africa and uh,
and trainings training.
I,
I get it.
Right.
I know training is not a fight,
but you know,
I've seen Floyd training videos too.
You know,
he looks good and Wesley looked good.
He looked fast.
Uh,
you know,
I didn't see how anyone could go through that and have the drug problems.
Everyone's said he had.
Um,
what about Mike Tyson?
Mike Tyson and he used cocaine problem and that's what he's coming out and
talking about now.
He fought when he was doing coke.
Yeah.
There's a different theme.
Crack and coke though.
Oh,
you can maintain healthy lifestyle on cocaine.
You want you to go to the pipe man.
So you're seeing that Wesley was on the pipe is I wish that that's what the
rumors were.
I never saw it.
Didn't know it.
Not For me,
but a lot of people told me that.
Well,
I've heard that about me though.
Not,
not about the pipe,
but about coke.
I've never done cocaine in my life ever.
But I've heard.
And why do they do that?
Cause your mandate?
I get a lot of energy.
Like when I do the UFC,
like when I do commentary,
people say,
Oh,
it's all cooked up to accommodate [inaudible] and coked up doing commentary for
the UFC.
My fucking head.
You were coked up at some point.
You would come down though,
right?
I would imagine.
Yes.
So I've yet to see that.
Well,
during the,
I mean I come down after the event.
Boy,
let me tell you like I used to do shows after the UFC,
I'll do the UFC and then get out,
you know,
10:00 PM in Vegas and then go to like the house of Blues,
do a midnight show.
But it was weird.
Too much energy,
like the energy that you put out when you're,
you're doing a commentary for like six hours of the UFC.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm on the whole time.
But it's natural.
And what do you FC is so intense.
I mean I think you
probably could do golf coverage,
right?
And then go and do a comedy set.
Yes,
I've done coverage for pool actually.
And then gone to done comedy.
No problem at all perhaps.
But you have seen like the jolts of fucking headcase.
You [inaudible] I hadn't been to a UFC since I was with you and it's like three
or four years ago before I went to the 20th yeah.
And you know,
and I know the 20th was pumped up.
I mean,
it was a pumped up event,
but still when you go,
you forget if you haven't been to a UFC live,
it's like God,
there's nothing,
there's nothing like this.
Nothing really isn't.
You know,
there's other great sporting events I've never been to,
uh,
you know,
the Superbowl a and maybe it's like that,
but there's just that feeling of anything can happen at the UFC still.
Yeah.
Even though I'm no longer in charge and there's a lot,
there's a lot of changes.
It still has that environment,
like whoa.
A lot of variables.
Yeah.
MMA has a lot of areas.
Well,
Lorenzo has a great saying.
He said that every event has an oh shit moment or where it happens and everybody
just goes,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
I mean,
how many times have you seen a result of the UFC and you look over and you see
fighters like John Jones or,
or,
you know,
Uriah Faber,
whoever it is,
sitting,
watching the fight,
holding their head going,
Whoa,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Like when Wii tour,
uh,
and fought Anderson and Anderson Front kicked him in the face.
I remember the camera scanning the crowd and you saw all these like pro fighters
going,
Oh shit,
oh,
you know,
that moment happened that yeah,
amazing stuff happens in a way,
a sudden way that you're not going to get in a sport like basketball or baseball
or football that has,
you know,
innings and round,
I mean innings and you know,
periods faking it in five seconds.
I mean,
Duane Ludwig want to fight in five seconds,
you know,
and anything can happen.
I,
you know,
I think,
uh,
I've come to enjoy boxing much more than I ever have from the last few years.
Uh,
basically I think,
cause I'm doing combat the Americas,
you know,
a Spanish version of the UFC,
if you will,
and just been around a lot of boxing and I like it.
I really do.
And when we started out,
you know,
you remember it was a real us versus them mentality with boxing.
Right.
And I think that's mostly gone.
Well,
the,
the Lou Dibella thing,
I had a thing with him on ESPN.
Well,
he's silly.
Here's the thing.
I mean,
everybody's like,
oh,
Joe Rogan hates boxing.
And people like whenever boxing does well,
people like tweet me things about like,
you guys blocked him.
He still did it.
Still Dead Sport.
Fuck it.
You know,
send me these thing on Twitter,
Facebook or whatever.
But I'm boxing fan.
I buy every boxing in paper view.
I watch every show time event.
I watch every HBO event.
That guy was just being a jerk off and when he was being a jerk off,
I had a clown him but I what?
I said,
I stand by one sec.
Genuis yeah,
he was being disingenuous.
He was not accepting the truth for what it is because it didn't fit in with his
worldview.
Well,
he was also using the human cockfighting analogy.
You know the all wear pants.
I said that once to an ESPN reporter kind of shut that thing down.
He goes,
is this human cockfighting no,
they're all got,
they all have pants.
That's the perfect.
I'm going to steal that please.
It's a gift.
Thank you very much,
sir.
That's the perfect thing to say when they say that.
That's such a dopey thing to say to no cock roosters don't know they're going to
fight.
Okay.
There's a big person trains.
They spend their whole life dedicated to learning these skills and then they
test themselves at the very highest level.
He was at chess promoter.
You might take that from him,
but he's a boxing promoter.
It's not such a cerebral sport.
Right.
Not only that,
it's not,
it's MMA boxing in it,
like the idea that it's a stupid saying,
you know like that or it's a stupid thought process that would allow someone to
criticize or not like other effect of combat sports,
kickboxing.
I'm a huge fan of kickbox like glory that's on spike.
I fucking,
every time one of those on I tweeted,
I watch them all.
They're fun.
I mean,
I'm a huge fan,
but just there's no taken down or glory.
She owns part of my company now.
Does he really?
Oh,
okay.
I didn't know that.
Pierre and around.
Okay.
I know they'll your rocks.
Are you kidding?
You watch those fights I told,
I told the UFC a long time ago.
I was like,
you guys should buy k one k one was struggling,
but he actually won.
It was hard to do though,
Joe.
Uh,
you know,
cause it was,
you know the guys with these fingers,
right?
Missy?
Yeah.
It was a lot of uh,
you know,
you go in a meeting and guys are missing fingers,
so you go,
well then right after glory there was a,
it's showtime.
It's show time,
put it on a lot of like really high level fights.
And then there's lion fights in a,
in Vegas Moitai though.
But still scale boxing.
Why I like really ties,
a lot of people don't know,
like kickboxing,
they allow you leg kicks,
but they usually have rules on how long you can hold the back of the guy's head
in the clinch and they don't allow the elbows to the face.
Um,
so because of those limited rules,
a lot of like the real moitai purest feel wear pants too.
No,
no,
no.
Can't do the human cockfighting.
You gotta wear shorts.
Actually you can't wear pants.
But the um,
the elbows to the face in the clinch,
it's,
that's an a really effective tool.
I think it's a mistake to take that out and it's um,
you know,
glory by doing just straight punching and you know,
sort of Dutch style kickboxing touched it well,
but then that then you can do it in New York and you know,
there is an advantage to those rules.
That's true.
The elbow as well.
And also the elbows.
Elbows are a very,
very effective weapons.
Like I don't buy that elbows just cut people.
You know,
that was a,
a,
an argument a while ago,
but the reality of a standing elbows is we're seeing them more and more used
inside the octagon with incredible effectiveness.
Have you ever seen Jordan Meehan when he fought a Cyborg?
Did you ever see that he fought a know cyborg evangelists,
sta work.
Santo,
I know he was,
he nailed that.
The Americas,
we had him,
we had him demonstrate
me and m e I n versus a sideboard finished him off with this standing elbow
combination.
When you get to really see how effective a guy who really knows how to throw
elbows can be,
so I think Gloria should probably leave,
you know,
the rules the way they are because they can get in New York.
But if it wasn't for New York,
I would say standing elbows and just Moitai rules in general.
There's,
there's something like,
there's something important about the various uh,
various tools like grabbing the back of the neck and knee to the face and need
to the body,
like using that plum clench and work in the body over.
It's a real,
it's real,
you know,
it's real effective and you chop that down and don't allow the clench and then
you chop it down further and don't allow elbows.
I mean,
you get some great fights like all the k one fights.
Well,
I mean,
we're all,
you're hearkening back to the early days,
right?
I mean,
um,
uh,
all the controversy aside,
finish this is the end.
Yeah.
He hit him with a body shot and then another left hook.
This,
Jordan,
me and kit is a really badly this lead,
this combination,
the elbows.
One,
two,
three,
boom,
boom.
It's fast.
It's slow motion.
That's not slow motion.
What a combination of elbows.
I mean,
unbelievable elbow combination.
That was just fucking beautiful.
See that?
That's a,
that's real.
You need to do.
Yeah.
I can't even remember how we started Joe.
You know,
it wasn't,
everyone goes,
hey,
there are no rules.
One man in her six men leave,
you know,
whatever we were saying,
but you know,
we couldn't figure out how to put the different fighting sports together.
Right.
So w whose rules to use,
right?
I mean,
and so really the basis of the UFC was always,
you know,
no rules became,
this huge thing.
But it was also,
whose rules do you use?
I mean,
how are you going to get a boxer against the Jujitsu guy?
What are you going to use?
You can't,
there's no rules you can use.
Did anybody try to gouge eyes?
Was that,
was that legal in the early one?
Well,
you know,
you know what I mean?
I always would hear about these wing Chun Masters.
They'd had 50 ways to pop your eye out with their thumb.
And I kept calling them going,
bring your thumbs and do it,
man.
Don't talk about it.
Come and pop everybody's I,
yeah,
I want you to have done,
if a guy lost an eye though,
would you have done it?
Would we'd pick it up?
What do you,
what would we do?
You know,
come on.
There's also,
there's a,
there's a reality to fighting that you know,
better than most people on the planet,
right?
If you're defending yourself,
you're defending yourself.
Whether it's from a right hook,
you know,
right cross,
uh,
an elbow or a knee or having your eye guide gouged out,
you're blocking,
you're,
you're aware.
You know,
guy comes at you with his thumbs up to do the gouge.
You're,
you're in a defensive position.
Well,
it is interesting though,
how many people are getting poked in the eyes now when it's illegal and how
often it happens and what you,
the reality of how devastating the results are.
When guys get their corneas scratched and they get a fingernail in the eye,
they get a finger jab in the eye.
Even if it's accidental,
man,
they scream and run away and
eyes are sensitive.
Is it any different in other sports?
The same in football.
If someone gets their hand inside the helmet,
it's same.
You know boxing,
you don't,
in the old days,
guys used to do stuff to the gloves versus
Davey Moore.
He thumbed them in the eye and the,
well he was kicking his ass anyway,
but Davey Moore couldn't see out of design then Roberto beat the fucking shit
out of him.
So you know,
the UFC didn't invent this.
No.
Thumbing is a long time strategy in boxing and they actually develop gloves that
have the thumb pinned down because of that.
Because in the old days,
the thumb would detach from,
from the,
uh,
the glove.
And even when it's like stitched in a little bit,
you could still kind of get it in there.
You can get it in there if you're just trying to poke a guy in the eye.
Which many people did do.
That's a definitely
dirty trick.
Well it is a fight.
Yeah.
You know a guy man with shamrock quiz to who I've,
who did he fight?
This was like UFC three or four.
He said it maybe one of the preliminary,
someone reached into his speedos and moved his cup out of the way so he could
knee him and Kevin was going,
dude,
we're fighting,
you know,
if you want to we can get together later.
But for right now,
hands out of my speedos
fight between Gary Goodridge in the Pedro in Brazil.
Famous fight.
It was like straight up valley Tuto,
no gloves,
no rules.
And Gary Goodwood's reached into his fucking pants and grabbed his balls and
crushed them.
He was in Gary.
Good.
Which was against that is the cock fight.
Yeah,
hardware we're talking was kept.
Pretty sure it was Gary Goodrich.
That doesn't sound like his style,
but you know,
back in the day,
yeah.
Here,
let me,
well he was in arm wrestling champ,
so maybe he figured that was playing to his strength.
He will yank your Franklin.
This was,
I'm pretty sure it was Gary Goodrich.
Yeah.
Garrett Goodrich versus the Pedro.
This was way back in the day from 1997.
And uh,
he uh,
yeah,
fishes grades and isn't back in the day.
Yes.
It is still back in the day to me.
Not to you while you were in retail,
you were in the game for four years by then.
Yeah.
Dude,
he reached into his pants and fucking crushed his balls.
You know what a Forrest Griffin said to me at the 20th anniversary,
he goes,
you know,
I love the early UFC.
He goes,
I would have entered earlier,
but I didn't want to wear those speedos.
I wanted to wear a man's pants.
That sounds like something for us with.
So when you guys first created,
yeah,
the UFC in 1993.
How long did it take from the initial idea?
First paper view?
Whoa.
You know what,
nobody's ever asked me that Joe,
you know,
uh,
w art Davey called me to pitch me war of the worlds in April of 93 and we were
on a November really?
So,
and you know,
and you need three month lead time for pay per view.
So you know,
it was like,
it was a go.
Wow.
So you guys realized right away what a great idea this is going to be.
Oh it,
I realized that on arts call,
you know,
how can you not you same with you.
You saw it,
you loved it.
You know,
I heard about it.
I,
I really did see it as alive,
you know,
a real like mortal combat.
That is really what I saw when I imagined what it would look like,
you know?
And I thought who would not watch that?
I'm watching it.
It's my show.
I probably would pay myself to watch it.
I mean just how can you not watch that?
I got a board,
a,
like I said in [inaudible] 94 I found the video of a UFC two and I don't think
UFC one was even available on video.
Right?
Wasn't there substitute dispute?
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't a dispute.
But um,
don gold,
you know,
should we all know and love and it's still at the UFC,
he bought two and at the same time bought one.
Um,
and back in those days you try to release the videos to be fresh.
So he didn't want to release one before too.
We wanted to to be the first one come out very close to the event,
all the Hoopla and then later on added one also,
as you know,
one had arguably the worst commentator team in the history of sports.
Feel good,
Tim Brown.
Jim.
I like Jim Brown.
Jim Brown was cool then I still think he's cool,
but what's super foot man?
Super Moron.
You know,
how dare you?
How dare you.
Goddamn hero was a karate hero bill.
Super Foot Wallace is that he's a karate hero.
I thought he was karate hero.
Is that what he did?
Oh,
he was a bad ass.
Kickboxer did you not know lock sir?
Of course.
I knew I was standing backstage and I'm trying to explain to him the name of the
show.
Right.
Which is not the ultimate fighting challenge.
I could,
you know,
maybe it's just a subtle difference,
you know?
But to me it meant a lot being chip versus challenge.
I'm trying to explain it to him and he is practicing his kicks over my head.
It's not,
I'm,
I'm not such a tall guy,
but he was a high kicker.
Right.
So he's doing these kicks over my head as I'm going build,
try to remember the name of the show.
So he's just showing off or something.
What is he doing?
I think he was dead.
He being silly.
Yeah.
And just showing he was too cool for school.
Yeah,
I got it.
And I said to him,
I go,
we're going to see any kicks like that.
And he goes,
I know you do that in a real fight.
They'll rip your balls off.
I'm like,
dude,
isn't that what you teach
now?
He's a jerk off.
He's not a hero.
You know what he did,
Joe?
There's only a couple where there's actually more than a couple of people.
I'm,
you know,
maybe still annoyed that back then before email,
right when you wanted to communicate something,
you had to write it down,
put it in an envelope,
use a government issued like form of sticker thing.
You put on an envelope and you sent it through a government process and it was
called the mail.
Right.
Okay.
So there is no email.
So bill super foot shows up,
gets the name wrong,
burps into the thing,
pays no attention,
does a horrible job,
takes the money.
And then like three days later in black belt magazine and editorial comes out
how he says he's totally against it.
So he must have written that before he died six weeks before,
you know,
so he just did it for the check.
I,
he did it.
Uh,
I dunno.
I mean it wasn't that big a check.
There's probably 2,500 bucks.
I mean,
if that was life changing for him,
he's in bad shape,
but I think he didn't like it,
didn't it?
I like a lot of the guys that I think of his paper Tigers [inaudible] right.
I think it was a threat.
Well you can't call bill super foot walls.
A paper.
Tiger bill super foot walls was a great kick boxer.
He really was.
He,
I saw him fight live.
He was a bad ass kick boxer.
I saw him fight live deep into his forties.
He came out of an era of kickboxing when they're really,
when it really was a great thing to watch.
Right.
And he was a great kick boxer from the Chuck Norris.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And there was a bunch of guys,
what's his name?
Um,
uh,
Rick.
Rufus.
Yeah.
I tried to get him,
uh,
Benny the jet or key.
Yeah.
I mean I was after all these guys and it was just a little bit too late in the
day for them.
Right.
Benny Benny was,
they were retired and you know,
and you're right,
I shouldn't go off like that as a kickboxer.
He was something he really just didn't enjoy working with them.
I didn't enjoy working with them.
I thought it was bullshit to show up.
Ready to condemn something or already have condemned it and not paying enough
attention to get the name right and something that was his history making as our
first event.
But anyway,
we'll now he met her,
they were horrible because it just goes down in the record books.
That's the worst commentating team of all time.
Well,
it goes down as the beginning and everything's,
I mean,
I sucked when I first started doing it too.
It just,
no one,
no one had any background in it.
No one knew what to do.
You know?
You know,
I didn't know about your fighting background when I asked your manager to do it.
What I liked was your comedy style.
I liked your persona and when I talked to Jeff,
he goes,
you know,
he was a kickboxer or something,
I forgot what he said.
It was like,
it wasn't very specific.
I was like,
really?
He was a fight.
That's how I found out about it.
But I always thought you were,
you had a tough guy persona that seem very right for the show and we needed
someone,
God knows that could talk when all hell was breaking loose because hell broke
loose pretty regularly in those days.
You had a couple guys that were doing the post fight interviews that just
weren't so good at it.
They just weren't so good at media.
Like Tony Blauer,
who's a really good martial artist and he's a lot about self defense and we had
to choose between people that sorta knew what was going on and real announcers.
Right.
I mean that was the choice because we couldn't find anyone.
Do you know Brian Kilmeade?
You know,
started out doing this too.
Is Brian?
Me?
He's on a show called Fox and friends.
You know,
it's like you started out doing this.
He did.
Oh,
I know exactly what that guy is through five I think.
And Brian,
if you're listening or anyone knows Brian,
I'm sorry if I got the number wrong,
but you know,
and Bruce back.
Excellent.
Good.
[inaudible] Nick,
you know Bruce,
back to this day,
I owe a,
Bruce had debt of gratitude.
He gave me some really good pointers.
When I first started doing the post fight interviews.
He gave me some real good pointers on like,
you know,
like what to say or what to save.
You're stuck and you know,
like how did he,
he's a pro and he's a really good guy in jail.
So did Blotnick you know?
Yeah.
He'd have great guy.
That was good.
Yeah.
Olympic gold medalist,
I mean,
awesome do to really,
really,
he was a great guy.
It's so sad when he passed.
I really miss that guy.
He was a really fun guy to do a commentary with two,
just to real genuine,
nice person.
Gotta be around,
had this
like before the show or backstage or if there was any problem.
He was unflappable and it just kind of gave off a calm.
Sure.
It sort of help cause like not everybody on the team was calm.
Right,
right,
right.
He was,
he was a great wrestler to knew a lot about wrestling,
you know,
and eventually developed his knowledge of a MMA,
Jujitsu skills and was really interested in learning.
You know,
I remember there's some videos of him rolling with frank shamrock like very,
very early in the day back,
I think when frank was the champion and a,
you know,
it's about the time of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I left right when frank one,
when he beat Kevin Jackson an Armbar them in Japan.
I didn't go to the Japan show.
That was when I quit.
I was like,
that's,
when did you quit?
About 98.
Somewhere around then,
which is right about on when frank won the title of c at that point I would
[inaudible] I really was.
It was,
it was weird for me too.
It's like,
it's um,
you know,
it was all these little tiny propeller planes to these strange places,
Augusta,
Georgia and doeth.
And that wasn't,
you know,
I kind of liked the Gusto.
I,
you know,
I mean,
that wasn't bad.
Good Barbecue.
Yeah.
Good Barbecue and somewhat friendly town.
You know,
only supposed to Charlotte where they invited me never to return.
The chief of police said to me,
if you come back,
I'm not sure what,
I will arrest you for it,
but I guarantee you I will arrest you.
Wow.
What year was this of police?
What year was this?
Well,
that would have been five.
So 95.
Wow.
What a Dick.
The chief of police and it's like a guy and it's the same.
Do you remember his name?
Dick something.
Hey Dick,
go fuck.
We eat,
I think dick weed.
Oh No.
What is that going to remember the,
I mean,
come on.
What a crazy abusive power.
It all,
it's all good now because John McCain said he would have ventured to him.
Now it's okay because the war here,
I said it's okay.
You know,
it wasn't me.
Mccain,
I've said this before,
like I was sort of hoping Jerry Falwell or somebody would come out against,
you know,
somebody I could take,
a war hero and,
you know,
powerful senator.
But you know,
who was really a tough opponent to counter was that,
um,
the senator from Colorado that it had the judo champion.
He'd been an Olympic judo con.
Um,
Ben,
he was native American.
Ben Light Horse Campbell and Nighthorse Campbell.
I don't know.
He is,
I'm never heard this before.
You know,
because we were kind of intimating that McCain didn't really know anything about
the martial arts.
And he went and found Ben who was an Olympic gold medalist in judo or a
medalist.
He might not have been gold.
And he said,
yeah,
well that's no good.
You can't do,
you can't do sail boats.
What are you thinking?
Can't use elbow or whatever.
He said,
who knows,
whatever the,
whatever it was,
he didn't like the early opponents.
And that was all for a lot of folks that don't know,
this is where it gets weird with John Mccain,
John Mccain's wife,
their family was involved with Budweiser.
Right.
And he was,
the Budweiser was in bed with boxing and boxing was in bed with the UFC.
Now,
I mean [inaudible] 93 so I don't really think that's the connection.
I don't think that's what it was.
It was,
I think it's odd.
I mean John Mccain,
you know,
is a Republican,
so republicans tend to stand for state control right at,
you know,
keeping a small federal government.
That's kind of a Republican policy.
But I think John Mccain really wanted a national boxing commission and I think
that this was a good way to promote that.
And I think he just was generally offended by the UFC and I think it was a great
way to get press and it wasn't like people were coming out and going,
keep the you will to keep the,
you know,
he just could beat on the UFC and get as much press as he wanted and look,
look,
look how different America is now.
I mean back then that was the biggest problem facing the u s was the UFC.
I mean now look at the problems facing America and the world and you go,
we really lived in kind of a magical time.
You know,
what do you mean the UFC was the only problem?
The United States as well.
You not reading the news in 1993 the word?
Well,
there's always things going on overseas.
There's always things going on that had you heard of Osama bin Laden in 1993 and
know that sense of gassed and that was a Russian problem.
Yeah,
that was the mujahideen back then.
Yeah.
They were fighting the Russians,
so they were cool with us.
Yeah.
I think Clinton years,
the economy was good.
I mean he got,
you know,
he did build the intern.
I mean that was like the biggest thing.
Or she did a them or whatever.
I wasn't paying it.
Yeah,
that was the biggest issue.
Well,
I'm sure that what I was going to say.
I mean,
what I mean is there,
there was certainly other problems in the world.
There's some violence and all sorts of things and are not,
if you were reading the media apparently,
you know,
it was,
well maybe it was you because you were really close to it too,
you know?
I'll tell you what,
for me it was,
uh,
you know,
it was riding the tiger,
right.
Because,
you know,
it was great to be in mad magazine.
It was great to be the final episode of friends when Courtney Cox's boyfriend,
Anders the UFC and goes into it.
It was great to be in virtuosity,
you know,
the Denzel Washington Russell Crowe movie.
I mean,
there's a bit,
there's big 95.
I mean,
it's really big media stuff,
but on the other hand,
when you're that visible,
you know,
you're making a lot of people angry if they,
if they don't like you,
you're in their face all the time.
So it was kind of a tough thing.
So,
yeah,
I mean it was fun until it wasn't.
Um,
and you,
I mean,
you know the story we were,
we had backed off that marketing and where,
you know,
the unified rules,
we're coming into place and you know,
it was a very
difference,
well for a lot of folks who don't know what we're talking about,
when the UFC first came out,
there were no way classes and there were no rules and you could not,
you know,
a fighter could tap,
they could,
but the no one could throw in the towel and the referee couldn't stop them.
But that was on one at changed by two.
That was insane
by the way.
Yeah,
that was insane.
Okay,
so what is this sort of highlights it.
So that's the first episode,
the first UFC,
and then from there,
slowly but surely rules start becoming implemented.
Strategies,
change rounds,
um,
weight classes,
gloves,
things got really interesting,
really fast.
And I'll think a lot of people were unaware of it.
If you think about the difference between 93 and 97 I came in in [inaudible] 97
when v tour made his debut gloves.
We're still not mandatory.
They were optional.
Some fighters fought without gloves.
Um,
but it was,
it wasn't that the case.
Yeah.
I was against gloves after I saw tank knock out.
What's his name man to uh,
um,
tank was smart.
He figured out he goes gloves or a weapon.
I'm bringing them.
Yeah,
you get hit harder with gloves,
a lot harder.
You can hit harder.
You don't worry about breaking your hands.
There's a,
and all the wraps and everything,
they give you a much better thing to hit with bare knuckles.
Tricky.
If you hit someone in the knuckle with bare knuckles on your forehead,
you can break your hand very easily.
It's a really common,
especially if you catch them with the last two knuckles,
the ones that vibe where you,
where your pinky is,
your head.
That was the most common
jury in the earthquake in hand.
You know,
on the Gracies wear.
Like wear gloves,
don't wear gloves where I had,
I don't care.
You know,
whatever you want,
where fast.
We don't care if someone else is wearing gloves and you're grappling with them,
you actually can hold onto the gloves.
I mean if there's a no rules about it and guys use the gloves to finish
submissions now too.
They started doing a lot of that.
A lot of guys.
Um,
um,
the way Josh Thomson finished off,
uh,
who was it?
Um,
uh,
Ryan,
he,
Pat Heeley thing was pat Heeley.
No,
not pat Heeley.
Yeah,
it was,
I think it was Josh Thompson and Pat Heeley.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
he grabs the glove as he's finishing the rear naked choke.
Like he's gone for the rear naked and he switches to palm to palm and then he
grabs the glove and use this as the glove to finish it off.
And I was like,
Huh.
I was like,
that's slick.
Well,
it's totally legal.
Yeah,
it's totally legal to grab your own glove and Tulsa totally legal to grab your
own shorts,
which is kind of interesting because one of the best ways to defend against
Camorra's is to just grab the inside of your shorts,
like by your crotch and just hang on for dear life.
I mean,
the Gracies always used the g for that type of effect.
You don't,
you know,
I'm sitting here,
I'm watching you do this right.
And I was watching your brain try to find that,
you know,
find out opponent and you know you are,
you're a renaissance man of tough guys.
You know,
that's what you are,
you know,
cause your comedy is like that.
You've acted
as a tough guy.
You do comedy from a tough guy,
point of view.
And you know,
I think you've probably,
is this true?
I think you've probably seen more MMA than anyone on the planet up close.
Maybe Joe Silva seen more than me because I've seen him.
He's over there.
He's got his hands over his eyes.
It was Pat Healey who it was definitely Pat Heeley.
Josh Thomson fought.
Um,
yeah man,
look,
I've seen a lot of up close.
I've been to,
I don't know how many events,
but I've seen well,
well over a thousand fights,
like up close and personal and some of the best fights in the history of MMA in
the history of Joe Silva goes,
saw the Fox sports one events as well.
Now,
like over the last two years,
he's outpaced me.
It used to be,
we would all,
we would not see the same amount of fights over the last two years.
I don't really do those Fox sports one ones as much anymore.
I do Fox and the paper view and then the Anik Florian team does the,
uh,
the other one.
But uh,
so Joe Silva might be the only guy on the planet that seem more fights than me
unless,
you know,
really hardcore fans.
There's some fucking psychos out there.
I've seen everything,
every local show.
It's hard.
I think Joe fits into that category.
He's a psycho.
Joe Silva is a real MMA fan.
That fucker loves MMA.
Yeah.
Here it is.
This is Josh Thompson finishing off Pat Heeley put up beautiful technique too.
He's got the body triangle and then he's using,
it's hard to tell here.
Nope,
that's palm to palm.
I'm wrong.
That's just a regular palm to palm grip.
I stand corrected unless he finishes it in a different way and pulls the gloves.
I definitely have seen someone do it before.
I don't know why I thought I thought it was Josh because Josh is a very clever
guy.
He's a the point stands.
It's a good move at that point.
Does it fucking Badass technique though?
Let me say no,
I couldn't tell if he did it there.
Is that John pulled out yet?
I was John McCarthy.
No,
no.
He's wearing a microphone.
You Fuck Jesus Christ.
It's like as he's finishing this off with a bar.
That's another thing too.
That's changed over the years.
That body triangle man,
guys,
uh Oh yeah,
he doing it.
He is doing it.
He was doing it at the end.
See my memory is good.
Thought my memory fails me.
Josh Thompson is a bad motherfucker.
Could you do too?
You know,
so much of the fighting has changed.
I mean it's,
yeah,
it's incredible,
right?
It's,
it's really,
it's,
it's like,
you know,
like even when you see old films of the,
the NFL back in the leather Helmer football on the leather element days,
you know,
football hasn't,
I mean the UFC changed more.
Y'All hit 20 years.
I mean,
it's remarkable.
But yet you and Joe Silver still there.
Yeah.
That's weird.
It changed radically.
And I brought both you guys in.
You did.
I was,
uh,
the post fight interviewer,
I'd never done any commentary ever.
Um,
I had done commentary for more time.
but I'd never done talk or,
well yeah,
but it's still,
you have to learn how to do it.
Absolutely.
And you've got a lot better.
Right?
Oh,
for sure.
I was in the beginning.
It's,
um,
but you were better in the beginning people that we brought in on that first.
Oh yeah.
Maybe while we're in a serious upgrade,
I had a,
the,
the benefit of a,
first of all of watching them make mistakes,
that's a huge benefit.
Enough.
And then the other benefit was I was a huge fan and always have been,
I've been a fan since that tape that I picked up at that Hollywood video store.
Uh,
and that was two.
That was notice number two.
Yeah.
And then I started training fuck out was,
I started training soon after that.
Um,
and uh,
I remember thinking,
man,
this is a,
I hope this works out.
You know,
I hope this takes off.
Cause I remember when I looked at the very box that had the UFC on it,
the first time I found out about the UFC,
I looked that box and went,
wow,
they did it.
They did it.
Because this is something that everybody in MMA had talked about,
I should say MMA,
everyone in martial arts,
and they were our,
no martial arts anymore.
There's styles,
but everything is essentially in my eyes,
MMA is martial arts now.
It's not,
I mean these ideas or martial arts.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think they're still teaching kids tae kwon do and there's nothing wrong with
it.
There's nothing wrong with it.
No.
But martial arts is MMA,
you know,
it is martial arts.
And,
um,
when we were coming up,
like I was a taekwondo guy and you know,
I had friends that did that,
did karate,
and I had another friend that did this and everyone always wanted to know what
was the best.
And you didn't know.
You really had no idea.
You had no idea until the UFC came along.
It was all just speculation.
And everyone was convinced that their style of judo was unstoppable or there
showed,
oh,
con was the best death touch and you know,
whatever it was every,
it was all just shit talking and guesswork.
But when I looked at that box,
I remember very clearly thinking in my head,
wow,
they fucking did it.
They actually did it like this was the thing that everybody always talked about,
getting everybody together,
make them Duke it out.
Kuma taste style like a fucking John Claude van Damme movie in a cage.
But even better because he was in a cage.
But we'll have to gun two.
But I would tell people when I was working for you guys,
I was a on news radio,
which is an NBC Sitcom.
Fortunately News radio was not doing well and wasn't popular,
so the network didn't come up to me and go,
hey,
fuck head,
what are you doing?
Cage fighting and commentator for the advertisers are very uncomfortable with
your side Gig.
They didn't have any problem because that show could have been canceled every
year.
Almost got cancer.
It's a good show,
Joe.
It was a very good show.
It was a very good show,
good character,
but we didn't have the benefit of political backing.
So we got moved a lot.
And uh,
it was never like a guarantee,
but when I was doing it,
people would talk to me like I was doing porn.
They would talk to me like I was off like shooting porn on the weekend.
They're like,
what are you doing?
You doing cage funny.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you,
why are you interviewing cage fighters?
I was like,
I like watching it and people would look at you like,
there's something wrong with you for liking.
Once I like watching a dude,
I'm telling you,
man,
I got seriously judged by,
by people in the industry back then
when it was not popular at all.
When I moved to Larchmont,
which is a snooty little town in Westchester outside of New York,
my wife goes,
please don't tell anyone what you do.
You know,
the UFC had paid for the house.
She goes,
please don't please if you could not bring it up.
Yeah.
It's,
it's much,
much,
much more acceptable now.
I mean,
no,
absolutely not.
Fox,
it's a,
you know,
it's rumored to be an Olympic sport in the making so well that would make sense.
But you know,
if you have curling as an Olympic sport might be your people.
You Canadian well Scottish,
which is oh,
the Scottish curl as well.
Right?
Well they invented curling and,
and the Canadians are Scottish because you know that drink Canada dry.
The Scots thought that was a challenge.
So they all went to drink Canada dry,
you know,
that's,
oh,
it's an old joke or sorry,
the three Scottish listeners you have are busting a gut right now though.
I love the Canada dry material.
I was on a one of those shows like best damn sports show or something like that.
Way,
way,
way back in the day.
And uh,
I was telling them,
I said,
I think it's going to be an enormous national sport one day.
And they were laughing.
They thought it was hilarious.
You know,
there's a lot of stick and ball guys in the sports business that still are
waiting for it to go away.
Like they don't like rock and roll or hip hop either.
Well there was some shit head on.
Um,
who does amateur football.
He does college football.
And he was talking about a,
after Anderson Silva broke his leg that this is the reason why he would never
cover the UFC.
Never has never will.
You know in MMA from chair what was the friends,
because Anderson broke his leg because this leg got broken.
Exactly.
And I'm like he's,
he works in football.
Football guy.
Yeah.
He's college football.
They don't even make money.
They're getting head injuries for free and the colleges are making billions of
dollars.
While the are no rules guys not commenting on other sports.
Joe,
I just,
I'm not doing that.
I had the no rules guy,
those guys,
those put those fucking higher moral ground sports guys there.
Yeah.
You,
but you know,
there's a real reason for it.
And it is.
And if you look at the NFL,
you know the,
with NFL films that turned the sport into heroic endeavor and I think NFL films
was really changing in,
in the media business and then the sports business cause they turn football into
this epic story and it became very advertiser friendly and you know,
ends up in,
you know,
the Superbowl,
which is the most advertiser friendly thing in the planet.
Right.
So I think that whole thing was built out and anything that rocks the boat,
the way we rock the boat with boxing,
when Tyson was moved from paper view to Fox opposite the ultimate ultimate back
in the day there hadn't been a heavyweight boxing match on broadcast.
And I think 16 years and strangely Tyson has put up against,
are a tournament of champions.
You know,
that's not a coincidence.
So I think when you're protecting something,
you know,
it's a siege mentality.
And I think a lot of the pure sports guys still feel a little bit threatened by
the UFC.
Well you better tell Dana White Cause Dana White,
we'll put shows on.
Well,
he used to always do that.
Put Us bike shows on opposite of affliction or opposite of Dana.
You know,
he likes to go to war.
I,
I am,
uh,
I am the number one Dana Fan.
I got to say,
it's like he's the greatest.
If it wasn't for him,
I wouldn't be working for the UFC this time around.
None of us would be sitting here talking about the UFC if it wasn't for him.
Well,
I had no intentions of going back and doing commentary.
I was totally talked into it by him.
I was watching the fights like cage side,
that's back when I'm Goldberg and I'm doing it with them.
Jeff from hooking,
shoot,
Jeff Osborne,
um,
and blatnick they were doing it.
That was a,
you know,
2000.
One or two.
Yeah,
2000,
2001.
So I was just watching
Dana.
Got It.
The way we,
the way I got it,
the way you got it instantly and then was in,
and then you're in and you,
you know,
and you're a Mormon.
You can't,
you know,
you're going to have four wives or whatever the special underwear,
whatever it is,
you are in a yeah.
In the UFC has that effect.
You know,
I,
you know,
I was in early,
no less today.
Are you shocked at all by the popularity of women's MMA?
Shocked is not the right word.
Um,
uh,
it makes sense to me.
Um,
you know,
I wanted to try women,
but we were in enough trouble with the cockfighting without making vagina
fighting.
You know,
we weren't going to,
we couldn't do that.
A different kind of boxing,
but I think it took a Rhonda,
you know,
and I'm a big fan of invicta too.
I think Sharon APP is really good and I think the Invicta,
those are fun.
Those are fun to watch.
And I think,
um,
you know,
a couple of the women fighters from a few years ago just for a little bit too
much ahead of their time and,
and now it seems like there's a critical mass plus this Rhonda,
you know,
who's the greatest,
I also like me should date very much.
Yeah.
It's fun to watch.
You know,
so if it's fun to watch,
it's gonna work.
And I also think the,
what Dana has figured out to do,
whether it's instinct or you know,
whether it's strategy or both,
he's like reinventing stuff every couple of years to just to change things up
and make it fresh again.
And I think,
you know,
the ultimate fighter is a good example of that.
Then I think the Fox broadcast deal and putting it in that spotlight and I think
Rhonda and I think it's like the sport is almost like,
I don't want to say reinvented,
but reenergized every couple of years.
And I think that's a very cool thing.
Yeah,
it's certainly a new element and it's new like seeing how many women are
becoming MMA fans,
not just because of watching the men fight,
but also now watching women fight as well.
You know,
in my,
in your favorite show other than the UFC,
he called the marine,
uh,
which was a bet show.
I data was sort of the hip hop UFC,
a huge female audience because we had great looking guys with their shirts off
and a lot of celebrities.
And it was a good formula.
And so women like that,
um,
you know,
I,
I'm doing this new thing combined to America.
So if you don't mind me,
you know,
plugging the show that's on Sunday on Munoz and what we're trying to do is reach
out to an audience that maybe has heard of MMA but is not familiar.
And I think that includes women too.
And it's all Spanish speaking.
It's a bilingual network.
Mundos is bilingual.
So when hoists Gracie is on,
you know,
he speaks in English.
When Eddie Alvarez is on,
If you speak Spanish,
you speak Spanish.
And so we've created a,
I've put together a thing,
uh,
called Gringo Wednesdays.
So Wednesday nights,
10 o'clock,
it's got English subtitles for those who Spanish is creaky me included.
Uh,
so next Wednesday if you want to check it out,
that's the first episode.
It's English subtitles and those that speak English,
we'll be continuing to speak in English and Combat Day.
American modern America's,
which means the fighting America.
So it's,
so this is your,
uh,
your,
um,
your highlight for it right here.
Two divisions that will test their hunger to become the next chip
they've even got what I got.
That's cool.
So how long have you been doing this for?
Will be shot at,
uh,
in the fall in Miami,
button.
Marie productions,
very famous TV company,
created the real world,
uh,
produced it for us.
Uh,
it's got a bunch of Spanish a stars.
I even,
I even tried to replicate a little bit of the Joe Rogan thing with a guy named
Pauline who's sometimes,
no,
not sometimes called the Howard stern of Spanish radio.
Uh,
is he have a martial arts background.
He loved boxing.
You know,
like an daddy Yankee who's in the show and someone I've gotten very close to
like you,
you know,
he had a professional fight background.
Daddy Yankee had five professional fights before he became a singer.
And you know,
you know the difference there,
like if you've actually had a fight for money,
you know,
it's a very different world.
And I think Daddy Yankee came to this like a lot of Hispanic fans do.
Knowing boxing and going,
you know,
the UFC is cool.
This is cool.
What's this about?
What's the,
you know,
what are they doing on the ground,
what kind of gloves or those,
you know,
like there's a lot of things that people we take for granted.
I mean,
you grew up in this sport,
you invented this sport to Joe.
I mean,
we've watched it develop,
but you gotta think if somebody has heard of the UFC but has never seen it and
they turn it on,
it's a very different thing.
You know,
you're on there,
it's intense.
They don't know what's happening on the ground.
They don't know the players,
they don't know the rules.
You know,
and I,
what I wanted to do is sort of reach out.
And then,
you know,
when I went to tell Dana about this last,
um,
last August,
I said,
look,
this isn't competitive with UFC.
I'm going after an audience that I think doesn't know anything about MMA.
You know,
I want to bring in this next generation of fans.
I'm doing it the US Hispanic market,
you know,
three times the size of Canada by the way.
And people talk about,
you know,
we're all going to be speaking Spanish in 20 or 30 years.
Yeah,
whatever.
But I know next year the majority of people in this country under 18 will be
Hispanic.
So it's a youth culture.
The majority of people next year,
2015 Mexicans know how to fuck.
Say how to put it down,
man.
Just the way.
That's the way you do it.
Don't say that.
No,
they don't.
They do.
This is good.
They'll know how to fuck.
Don't forget the Puerto Rican.
They know how to fuck to Dominicans.
They know how to fuck as well.
Long Beach,
they can fuck their brains out.
It's a fascinating statistic though.
That's a,
that's quite amazing.
We're in a youth business.
This is a,
this is a move to the youth culture.
Los Angeles has 21 Mexican radio stations,
21 Spanish speaking radio stations.
That's amazing.
21 stations,
one city that don't even speak
and I think po leans the number one drive time.
I'm not sure.
Don't know Spanish.
Train his name on billboards and shit.
So he's your guy.
He's,
he does kind of what you do,
you know,
he talks to the fighters,
gets everybody pumped up.
Does he understand Jujitsu at all?
You know,
it was,
he understands wrestling.
Again,
you know,
the background here is very different if you're a Mexican,
Mexican American,
you know,
Lucha Libra,
right?
And you know boxing and that's what you know,
but he's doing commentary,
right?
Yeah.
But remember this is,
this is a reality show.
We're introducing the guys.
We do fights on episode nine and 10.
And what I've done is sort of tell the stories of the guys and sort of involve
people in MMA and bring in hoists and bringing Eddie Alvarez and bring in people
to show them.
My,
the guys I'm using actually are pretty interesting fighters.
I've got a guy that's a sometimes called the Hispanic Kimbo slice level
Martinez.
He's got a million views on his youtube channel.
Backyard fights.
Very similar to Kimbo.
Uh,
so I've got an interesting group of guys,
but what I'm doing is I'm explaining it to the audience.
So we bring in experts to talk and been a voice comes in and he doesn't show
them Jujitsu.
He talks about the philosophy and mentality of a fighter.
You know,
and Eddie came in,
the guys were beat down from the competition reality show,
and then they had fights in about a week.
And Eddie Alvarez was,
you know,
he came in and he said,
at times you really tested and it isn't always tested in the cage.
You're tested outside the cage and he knows what he's talking about.
So I,
I want it to bring in guys that really meant something and introduce them to
these fighters.
So these guys saw,
you know,
class acts,
world class fighters and mixed it in with a bunch of Spanish celebrities and uh,
you know,
and,
and Dre Kanye,
you know what she,
I think she's the most beautiful woman in the history of MMA.
And she's the Co host.
She was a journalist.
We found,
she does Spanish language commentary,
pictures.
Jamie pictures
find Andres.
So does anybody see a l?
L E N?
[inaudible] do they have commentary where the people were fighting?
Absolutely.
And do the guys who are doing commentary understands Jujitsu.
Yes,
they do.
Yeah.
But no one has any experience in Jujitsu.
No.
Hmm.
So I'm hearkening back to my past.
Yeah,
we need you.
You need a guy to speak.
Speak Spanish.
No,
I don't.
Victora Davila who works for the UFC is,
well God damn son Jesus Louisa's that's her.
Oh my goodness.
That bodies ridiculous.
That should be illegal.
You know.
Holy Shit.
I'm telling you.
She knows more about MMA than I do.
Maybe not more than you,
but she knows cause I kept showing her to people.
Oh my Nigga got a picture of her ass.
Hold up.
Get.
That's my ass.
Get to that one.
There's no way that's never asked
to Jesus and dre.
I know you're listening.
He's saying this with love and respect.
Matrass fellow fellow bronchus respect for genetics.
What's in your federal broadcast or if you've got a thong on your asses up in
the air and your song in the show,
I wear a thong and a Cape you do to keep yet try to conjure up that image.
When do you wear a thong and a cane?
Why don't wear a thong and a,
what are you saying then?
Trying to discern information.
Yeah,
look at her ass.
That's the girl you work with.
POW,
POW.
You don't think she knows what she's doing?
She wants you to say that.
Campbell Mclaren.
That's why I apologize.
Um,
Joe Rogan,
Joe Silva,
Andrea Kayak.
So if no one understand,
if no one's my contributions can just get to do they know what the fuck's going
on when guys are scrambling on the ground.
Cause that to me was one of the most important aspects of,
you know,
you're,
you're 100% right and,
but you're right.
For my next season or the third season,
what we're doing now is trying to give an overview of what's happening.
Remember,
you are so deep in this.
You can't imagine anyone not knowing.
Take yourself out of this mix and look at it someone,
they don't even know why they're on the ground.
And listen,
believe me,
I completely understand people not knowing.
I have to explain sometimes to people what I do.
Like I've had conversations with people like on vacation or what have you that
have no idea who I am or what I do.
And you know that it'll come up.
Like someone will ask me a question and they'll go,
what's that guy talking about?
I'm like,
oh I do this thing and then I'll explain what it is.
And the look they give you when you cage fighting MMA,
you know what the cages in Spanish,
this is why I like,
you know,
Hispanic culture has really drawn me in the cage in Spanish is lot how la Blah
Blah.
Just sounds bad man.
It just sounds pretty bad.
Ass House.
Cajun Spanish is j u l a Ooh
cage starts with a j.
That's even better.
That's cool.
Um,
so how long have you been working on this format?
I thought of it.
You know what I,
you know when I was thinking about this is when I came to the UFC,
the Indianapolis show,
which is
four years ago.
You know,
cause I was at a,
I don't know if you remember,
I was really,
my mom was very,
very ill and I'd gone out to Indianapolis to see her and I wasn't going to come
to the UFC and I called you last minute and you and Dana always gentleman,
very great.
You say come sit with me at the event I was really depressed and I went out and
Dana was great.
And um,
you know,
I forget if it was you or Dan.
Someone said let's go go to the round card girls trailer.
I think it was Dana.
He goes,
why don't you stop in and say hello?
And I'm,
you know,
I'm married 28 years,
I'm happily married.
But yeah I went to the Aramco
trip cause cause I did just take a peek in there and just thought I'd
look and I thought,
you know,
these girls are so pretty and a really pretty girls,
but they're so skinny.
You know.
And I was thinking about the different,
something would look how everything would look different if you were doing MMA
for Hispanic rd.
That's fun.
And it was the girls,
pretty girls.
I mean,
you know the UFC round car girls or you could take them home to your mom.
They're beautiful.
They're wonderful.
They're skinny though.
Just skinny Asian girls.
A lot of them.
So we were thinking they would look more like Andrea Kai.
Yay the problem.
I ain't,
dre is so beautiful that around called girls kind of look.
They didn't match up to our host really well.
No,
they were okay.
They're,
they're okay too.
Yeah.
And we're doing a big contest here in La to find the next season's round card
girls now that's going on all around us.
Yeah.
What is it about people that think that girls are supposed to be skinny?
Like the will you ever understand that?
Well,
one who figured that out.
Like there's a lot of women that are actually trying to lose weight to get
skinnier.
It's not because they think that that's the ideal,
like to get like really thin,
like model type skinny.
They think somehow or another that that's attractive to men.
It's very bizarre.
Like this.
I guess some men must like it,
but most men that I know,
men or boys prefer that for that,
that big juicy as Kapow that God damn son,
I just a it seems unnatural.
The,
the real skinny skinny looks seems like it's weird that that's like a,
that's something that women shoot for.
And I think they do it for themselves.
Like the,
you know,
it's almost like for the,
the,
the approval of other women or the attractiveness of other women.
Like how like clothes and shoes.
Like I've heard women actually say that they dress that way for girls.
The girls,
depending on where you're going with this.
But I like it.
I'm ready.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not saying Lesbian Shit.
I'm just saying this is something weird that they,
they're missing.
They're missing a lot by what men,
like what men like is that chick you got pow wow,
don't you think?
Uh,
it's the women's point of view as men really don't notice that much unless
you're there naked.
So it's like,
well,
we notice when like women to look nice and dress nice and the woman who feels
confident in their clothes and all that good stuff,
but with health health is good.
You know,
it looks like she works out and you know,
symmetry and health are actually hallmarks of beauty,
right?
It's when you,
when you change that around,
that's when you start to get some strange.
Rhonda is a very beautiful woman and she's a a bronie chick yas.
Yeah.
Which is not your ass kicked my ass.
She's a,
she's a tough girl,
man.
She's tough.
She loves fighting and she,
she's the perfect person to be the champion and the emergence of women's MMA in
the modern era.
I mean,
Gina Carano was an excellent spokesperson as well for sort of a lot of the same
reasons.
She's an ass kicker and she's also very beautiful and very talented and very
tough.
But Rhonda is just some next level shit.
You know,
her judo is the best representation of judo in MMA.
Without a doubt.
The,
the fight with Misha Tate was a perfect example of that.
Her throws are there.
It's ballet man.
It's fucking magnificent.
Magnificent.
Gets a good way to describe it.
She's got the best arm bar setups in MMA period.
If any way class men,
women,
doesn't matter.
She's the best.
She hits those armbars from everywhere and the way she does is just fucking
laser sharp.
Everything's her.
Her transitions are sharp.
She doesn't even hold onto the legs.
It's one of the things she,
she finishes armbars like almost,
she's got like some crazy percentage rate of finishing.
And you know,
some people say it's harder to do that to women because they're just naturally
more flexible than guys.
This,
there's more give in the woman's joints.
Uh,
I don't know about that.
I think that's ridiculous.
The arms aren't as strong.
That's silly.
Anybody their cores on a strong,
that doesn't make any sense at all.
You do yoga?
Yeah,
I do yoga.
And do you do as well as the girls?
No.
Um,
I did pretty good.
I'm actually pretty good.
You know what?
You're,
you're,
you're a bad example.
Like when I go in to do the yoga,
they're laughing at me.
Why is that?
Because I can't bend over any direction.
Well that's you though.
You've got more representative in Mandan.
You,
well not the American man renaissance.
You ready to get onboard of true now I might get arm barred.
I do the challenge.
The got to get our butter and regular basis looks more like me.
This is true.
Um,
women are pretty easy to arm bar.
I had a girl say that to me once.
Oh,
uh,
I can't be arm barred cause my uh,
arm goes to farm,
double jointed in like,
let me show Ya.
I garbaria bitch.
Just relax.
That's a lawsuit.
Well,
it's not hard to do because first of all there's a bunch of different armbars
inverted armbars.
It doesn't matter how far your arm goes back cause you have so much leverage to
play with.
But the,
a just a standard arm bar,
you know,
it look,
Frank Mir broke,
um,
Tim Sylvia,
his arm and it wasn't even,
he was like far down on the,
on the the elbow.
He was actually break.
He broke the forearm.
And that's how crazy that technique was.
Leverage and strength combined.
You know,
someone's got a good arm bar.
Let me change the subject here.
Let me ask you something.
So you said you're pretty good at Jujitsu.
You better at comedy or Jujitsu comedy.
Interesting.
I've been doing it longer and it's more,
I don't know,
it's more a part of who you are,
you know,
I mean it's really,
comedy is a comedy is sort of like a living,
breathing thing that you kind of throw it and add to every day.
And Jujitsu is in a lot of ways as well.
But Jujitsu is uh,
something that your body,
if you do it on a regular basis,
you do it really like all the time,
five days a week,
six days a week,
your body breaks down,
you're just going to get fucking injuries.
There's no way around it.
Everybody's got neck problems,
back problems.
And I think the difference is Jujitsu is classic.
2000 years ago,
2000 years from now,
you can,
comedy is continually adaptive.
Comedies like a fight,
you're continually adapting,
right?
Comedy's changed though.
You know,
I think you,
you and Comedians have about your age represent the group that changed over,
you know,
I was in the comedy business for a long time.
I didn't know that though.
You Know Jeff?
Yeah.
I ran Caroline's ran catch a rising star managed joy bay harbor and you know,
manage Larry Day.
No Shit.
You know,
I mean I was deep in the comedy business.
That's how I knew about you.
Um,
you know,
and my first paper view was Andrew dice clay,
no shit.
Which he had a paper view yet to man.
I made a lot of money because she was banned everywhere.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
And it was really with Andrew that I figured out how to do the controversy in
lieu of a marketing budget.
Wow.
You know,
cause he was banned.
He was dropped by his manager,
his record label,
the movie company,
Hbo.
But yet he still had only sold out the super dome.
You know,
when he was performing.
I believe it.
I mean it was,
he had millions of fans.
They couldn't see him anywhere.
He's perfect for paper view.
Does the podcast all the time.
It's to me of him being a friend.
I mean he catches a lot of shit and caught a lot of shit from people that are
like very PC.
He's a character.
I mean that's where the Andrew dice clay is.
But to me he's a,
he's an all time great.
I think there's a,
there's a,
there's a handful of all time greats that I have like the 20 top comp comedians
ever.
I put Andrew dice clay in there because uh,
to me when I was a kid,
I remember when I was like 18 or 19 years old when I first found out about them.
I remember sitting in my car with my girlfriend laughing our ass off,
just crying,
laughing at dice clay about how funny it was.
And it was a cassette.
I was listening to a cassette in my car and that's,
you know,
that was like around the time I become a dice clay fan in the rhymes,
like the fact that people could sing along like they want it,
they,
you knew it was coming and you still left.
That's the first time that's ever happened in comedy because that's sort of
violates what comedy is.
What comedy is supposed to be supposed to sneak attack on you.
This is way too esoteric a conversation.
But do you remember Yakov Smirnoff?
Sure.
He reminded me a lot of dice because it was a very similar setup,
cartoony character,
but it was that there was one joke,
the government,
the Russian government is going to do something to you.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
and,
and Andrew was much bigger because he hit something that registered,
like the UFC registered everyone.
Do you know,
I
promoted his paper view.
We went to a George Foreman,
a press conference for his fight.
Dice walked in with a boxing robe,
one glove and a cigarette in the other hand.
Yeah,
dice come on a paper view.
And we,
we broke up foreman's press conference because we didn't have the budget to do
our own press conference and you know,
and I go,
I walked into that with Andrew and I go,
you know,
see they're going to work.
I'm,
I,
I'm gonna take a beating.
I'm really am going to get beaten up and throw them through a door.
And then George Foreman stood up and he lifted a dice.
Clay's one handed a one glove and lifted over his head and that was the picture
and that was it.
Man.
It was great.
Foreman was great.
That group surrounding George,
we're not so thrilled with my appearance.
Did they beat you up conference?
No,
we got,
you know,
we,
got out where the getting's good.
Yeah.
You know,
discretion was the better part of valor.
You've been involved some shady deals,
man,
that was shady.
So I think it's called guerrilla marketing.
Yeah,
man.
Guerrilla marketing.
Back when there was no paper view back when there was no internet,
no Internet.
You had to do things like that.
Right.
It had to be created social media,
you know,
to quote Betty White,
we didn't have Facebook,
we had phone book,
we had to call people,
do stuff,
show up,
you know,
it was different.
Yeah,
it's a completely different time.
It's hard for people to really wrap their head around the idea of promoting
something without social marketing now.
But back then,
that was the reality.
I mean he like,
you know,
I've been in martial arts my whole life,
but like I said,
I didn't find out about the UFC until was like UFC two was on videotape.
I really didn't hear about it.
I didn't know.
How would you hear about exactly know,
but whereas if the New York Times wrote,
you know,
death is cheap,
1495 tented sort of,
is that what they wrote?
Yeah.
I didn't read that either.
I don't read the New York Times.
Um,
I used to deliver it,
deliver it at times.
I'm not sure who reads the New York Times except people in the media.
Well,
and they read that they went bad shit.
New Yorkers and pseudo intellectuals worldwide who like to pretend that makes
them extra smart if they read the New York Times.
Well,
let me give a shout out to Richard Sandomir who still covering sports poorly for
the New York Times.
So I got to say he is one of the unsung heroes of the UFC.
If it wasn't for Richard Sandomir,
I'm not sure any of us would be here.
Why is that?
Because he wrote death is cheap.
1495 we would still be here fucked up outlet,
picked it up and wanted to interview me.
Jim Brown,
you know,
it went crazy.
It went crazy and I,
I'm not sure Richard was really trying to help.
I'm not sure.
I couldn't tell from,
maybe it was irony that he was using in the article,
but uh,
you know,
he asked me,
he goes,
you're promoting violence.
And I said,
you know,
there's gun violence,
which is an issue.
I said,
and this is the martial arts.
have you ever heard of a drive by kicking?
Which I thought was a reasonable thing to say.
And he said,
that shows what a sick sense of humor that guy has.
That's the kind of guy,
you know,
drive by kicking.
That's,
that's a sick sense of humor,
I guess to Richard's sand.
A mural of the New York Times.
Well,
people
like that get into positions like that and they make a mess of things.
He helped,
well maybe whatever.
Fuck that guy.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's just so many of those people out there.
And some of those silly people that have these really shitty personalities and
poor points of view,
their points of view suck.
And when you're expressing your point of view and you have the outlet,
like the media outlet,
like a New York Times,
you have that ability,
you can get incredibly arrogant.
You can get incredibly arrogant about your position,
your point of view and you know,
also incredibly arrogant about your ideas being more important than other
people's ideas.
You are a protector of the,
the moral high ground is the big one.
We experienced that a lot on fear factors.
Well,
people taking the moral high ground factor.
I forgot to add that in to your list of renaissance man of tough guy stuff.
You know,
where would Dave Chappelle be without fear factor?
Because that was clearly,
it was funny.
Please.
Clayton becomes the fucking blind.
A racist that didn't know that he was black.
That's the greatest sketches of all time.
That's the greatest comedy sketch of all time.
Dave would have been fine,
but yes he would.
But he did do,
uh,
their,
their fear factor was,
yeah,
that was a fun one.
That was fun.
What do you remember?
I don't remember.
I think it was fair,
fair,
fair.
He was on fear factor.
He was at the Tyrone begums was on fear factor.
Yeah.
That was fucking fun,
man.
We had to do that.
We had to do so many takes because I kept cracking up because Davis tire on big,
I'm just like,
I've known Dave since he was a kid since he was a teenager.
So it was,
it was,
it was beautiful seeing his show take off and being,
and I was a fan of it and being so funny,
but he's just always that guy.
When you're around him,
you're always laughing.
So what we're doing these things we had to do many,
many takes just cause people start cracking up.
The time I spent around you is divided into either laughing all the time or
you're on some ramps,
you're on some mission.
I like the look as the last time I was talking,
we started talking about punching in the UFC and I contend it did.
It could get better.
Yes it can.
And because you went from there,
well it can get better,
but there's a lot of issues,
you know,
um,
the gloves,
the boxing style that a lot of people are used to utilizing in actual boxing
match.
A little bit of it is dependent upon being able to block with those big gloves.
You know,
when you take that out you have a completely different thing.
I have war war machine was on the podcast recently and he was talking about MMA
sparring.
He's like,
I don't spar with big gloves anymore because it gives you a false sense of
security.
It gives you,
but isn't it the stick?
Don't you think a stance,
it's more of a factor.
Stance is definitely a factor.
You have to be more square in MMA to avoid the take downs.
And I'm seeing that with the Spanish guys that are all coming in from boxing.
Right.
And they're opening themselves up.
They're good.
Punchers though.
I mean Chris punchers and it's,
you know,
some of them would get eaten up in the UFC because they're leaving themselves so
wide open.
I'm very interested to see how that shakes down because most of these guys are
coming in.
One Guy,
Joey's dad is a pro boxer.
So He's coming in from that.
Uh,
how many wrestlers do you have on the show?
One guy from Mexico,
one guy,
two guns from Mexico.
Those guys are gonna win.
What's the one?
Yeah,
those guys are going to want and follow the,
put the money on the guys with the fucked up years.
Cause that was in the early days.
Ears.
Well the early days you're essentially going right back to UFC one.
Well you're,
you're kind of coming in at like UFC three or four.
It's more like five,
but yeah,
whatever point well taken.
Yeah.
These guys now they know something.
So yeah.
It's not like when we showed up and everybody goes in the pajamas,
pajamas,
I'm gonna kill him.
You know,
it was a,
it's no,
it's different.
They all know something's up.
But what do you do and how do you adapt to what you did before?
You do it all over again.
No worries.
You know,
you do it all over again and you let it adapt from there.
I think,
um,
it's something that every culture that gets exposed to MMA is going to have to
figure out for themselves.
And that's one of the things that I've met when we were talking about the Wesley
snipes thing that I don't think anybody,
I think he probably did think he was going to kick my ass.
You know,
I'm just like,
I thought I was going to kick his ass,
but if he had just rolled once,
just gone into trained once with go and enroll with here,
here on are Henner you know,
anyone,
anyone who really knows what they're doing.
Not saying that I'm those guys,
but role someone would feel how utterly helpless you are.
And then extract you get manhandled decent purple belt and watch how many times
you tap out in a minute,
you know,
just to purple belt.
Just some guy who you know knows what to do and you're not gonna be stop it.
You know?
I think that these guys are going to have to learn that.
They're going to have to learn how to stop the shot.
Because if you get in there with a world class wrestler,
you're going down periods,
stop all this nonsense about,
I'm going to go to the side,
I'm going to,
I'm going to duck under his take down and say,
bitch,
you're going on your pack.
You're going to be,
you're you to either figure out how to get back up or stop that from that dating
line by the church man.
I be on your back.
Yeah,
and then there's also an right,
it is that dominance thing really is to see fighters that didn't have a ground
game in the UFC be so man hang handled.
And it was like a prison scene from,
you know,
it was like a prison movie.
Even guys that got good,
like Pat Barry,
he recently quit.
He says,
I'm done.
Done with MMA.
I don't want to wrestle anymore.
He's going to go to a sign with glory.
He's going to do some kickboxing.
But he got to a point where he was on his way into the octagon.
It's like,
shit,
I don't want to wrestle.
You think there's too much ground in the UFC?
No,
no,
no.
Not a fear.
Not a fear factor for you.
No,
it's,
this is the problem.
That's reality.
But I've said this on the podcast many times before that I'm a fan of Ben
[inaudible].
Ben Asked her,
it was a guy who fought for Bellator.
He's a great guy.
And like in like Eddie Alvarez challenge outside loudly and maintain his dignity
and his,
his gentlemanly take on things.
You know,
I really,
I admire that because he,
and they had the same problem with rubbing knee Rubik knew whatever.
He's an excellent wrestler and um,
he gets criticized because he's able to take guys down,
manhandle them on the ground and punch him in the face and they can't do shit
about it.
And he takes guys like Douglas Lema,
like really high level guys,
shuts their game down,
just shuts it down with his wrestling.
That's important.
It's that cause that's reality.
That is the reality of fighting with that guy.
Douglas Lema might be more exciting to watch on television because he's a
devastating striker and he's really scary knocks guys out cold and maybe Ben
doesn't do that,
but so fucking what?
When those two get together,
what happens?
Ben Aspirin dominated Douglas Lema.
That's reality.
Whether or not it's fun and exciting to watch,
you can't change that and you can't,
you can't like regulate your sport to make things that are less exciting when
you're dealing with a sport that involves fighting because you can't like get
weight of the things that are less exciting.
Of course you can.
Why would you do that?
You have a real legitimate sport.
No,
no,
no.
You have a sport.
There's a lot of entertainment in that sport.
There's a reality.
Hold on.
There's a reality and being able to shut a guy down,
okay.
And a guy like her and can shut a guy down,
take them down.
That guy does not want to get shut down.
That guy does not want to get taken down.
Now,
if aspirin can utilize his martial art,
which is wrestling,
legitimate martial art,
and take these guys down and completely dominate them for five rounds,
tough shit.
You can't stop that.
Of course you can.
How?
Why,
how and why baseball pitchers are dominating,
lowered the mound.
Why did they do that?
Then they'll listen.
That doesn't make any sense.
It's not the pictures of famous,
but it's baseball.
You're,
you're talking about fighting is fighting.
Okay.
You can change the rules.
You could hold on a second.
You can change your rules,
but the up,
the objective is still the same thing.
The objective is still the throw a ball that a guy can't hit,
hit a ball to the guys throwing at you.
Catch the ball when it goes in the air.
The objectives are exactly the same.
The objectives in MMA or exactly the same to stay up if you can or take a guy
down and submit them.
If you can't stay up,
you can't stay up.
That is reality.
There is no way you can change that.
If you change that,
you're cheapening what you're selling because what you're selling is a martial
art.
You're selling.
This is as real as it gets.
This is what happens when two people who are incredibly skilled actually fight
using the skills they have.
If you handicap the guy's skill just for entertainment,
you cheapen the whole product cheap and the whole sport arguing with you on
this.
We keep in the sport,
I let's,
I tried to do this.
This is what we started out trying to do to make it as real as possible.
Well let's,
let's quantify what we're saying.
Let's quantify what you mean as far as like,
yes,
you can change it because if you're talking about like what are,
what are you talking about when you're saying you can change it to stop a guy
who some people perceive as being boring or make the fights more exciting?
Well,
for one thing,
you can not sign them to your franchise,
right?
I mean that's one thing you can do.
You can let them,
I,
I might,
I'm going to say go on record.
I think that's a mistake.
I think the UFC should've signed them.
If I was running things,
I would assign them in a heartbeat.
You know,
I really like Ben,
so you know,
I,
I wish him,
you know,
I hope it all works out and I wish I'd talked to him.
So he didn't talk shit about the UFC because he said a bunch of Shit and talk
some shit about Dana,
which is unnecessary.
I W I wish maybe the heat of the moment,
I'm sure.
Well,
he's a fucking proud guy.
He's a proud,
you know,
champion athletes and accomplished athletes.
That's one of like,
I,
I'm bummed out about that.
But say,
say I had a fight franchise and say it was called Combate and you can watch
it this Sunday on Monday.
Right?
So like one of the things I did,
like I have this,
the guys have a tradition of,
you know,
Mexican wrestling,
Lucha Libra,
right?
So I brought in a guy called the blue demon to show them stagecraft because
there are some things you can add to the sport,
right?
How you enter,
how you leave,
what you do after you win.
I think that's a really big part of this.
I think this is an entertainment too.
You know,
boxing,
uh,
Joe Louis always made more money than Babe Ruth,
right?
Cause there's an entertainment factor to what fighters do.
And you have to acknowledge that and the fighters have to work with that.
And I think sometimes it's put upon them with John Jones,
you know,
great fighter,
tremendous athlete,
really good athlete.
But the fight was Gutsy,
is the one that I think it was thrust on him and he had to show heart and he had
to work it through and he had to do all this stuff.
So that was fate.
That was Karma that happened to him.
But if that hadn't happened,
you gotta do something with a guy like that because the fans weren't responding
to him.
Wait a minute,
what are you talking about?
You're saying the fans weren't responding to Jon Jones dominating people choking
out low.
The Leo Machida I choking out rampage Jackson.
I'm not saying
people didn't think he was accomplished,
but I didn't see this surge in popularity that he should have had from those
accomplishments.
Wow.
I don't,
I don't agree at all.
I think he's incredibly popular.
I don't know.
I'm confused about that.
I don't know why.
Why would you think that you think you think is styled boring?
Like John is boring styles that we're comparing him to brand.
I would say methodical.
I'd say brilliant.
The best ever at keeping distance,
utilizing his specifying which fight is the most fun to watch?
Uh,
well the,
the Augustus and was that fight was the most competitive.
So that's probably the best one to watch.
But the way I was dominated the Rashad Evans fight was a great fight as well.
Do you think Gustafson was his best opponent is most scaled opponents?
I think Gustafson is very well.
It's all in styles and how they match up.
Gustafson matches up with him incredibly well.
He's a very good boxer.
And John Gustafson is also the first guy that ever father was taller than him.
That's a big thing.
You know what,
I think you really hit on it.
I think when you were asking what you can do to sort of keep the sport true but
have more entertainment,
you have to think about those match up.
This is what I think.
Yes,
but it's also about a matter of you've got to look if a guy's boring or you
think a guy is boring.
I don't feel like Ben Aspirin's boring,
but if a guy like Ben asking comes along that people feel as boring,
what do you want to see when you want to see him fight Johnny Hendricks.
That's what you want to see a guy who he's going to not really have a big
wrestling advantage with to see,
fuck yeah,
you kidding me?
I would pay mad money to see Ben aspirin fight Johnny Hendricks because Johnny
Hendricks knocks motherfuckers stiff.
I mean he's just a wrestler and he's a great rest.
Yeah,
he's a world class wrestler.
He might be a level below aspirin wrestling wise.
I believe he is,
I believe asked her just a little bit,
a little bit higher level wrestler,
but he's good enough that he can keep the standing.
I mean he might not have achieved the international a respect that astronaut has
wrestling,
but it's close enough,
close enough where I think Johnny can keep the fight standing and Johnny
Hendricks can punch holes through fucking steal that.
That dude hits hard and that's the difference between the two of them.
His fights or like the Martin Kampmann one punch knockout,
the John Fitch one punch knockout guys who we've seen are really durable.
They get hit by Hendricks and they go to sleep.
I want to see that fight.
I want to see if [inaudible] can do the same shit.
That would be awesome.
You know the only way you find that out,
you know a lot more than me,
but the only way you can find that out is to get a guy like asking and let him
use his shit.
We've got to find out if he can stifle Johny Hendricks.
He takes Johny Hendricks down and gives him fucking nuggies for five rounds.
Holy Shit.
Like what the fuck?
How do you figure out a way to stop that guy?
Because you're dealing with a guy like in Hendricks,
obviously he didn't do this,
but if he did do this,
you're dealing with the guy that when Hendrix who went five rounds with GSP and
most people thought he should have won,
and GSP is widely regarded as if not the best pound for pound fighter ever.
At least top three ever.
So if Johnny Hendricks can get stifled by Ben asked him,
what the fuck does that say about Ben askers wrestling?
He got to find out,
you got to fucking throw him in there.
If you don't throw them in there,
it's in a legitimate sport.
You've got to find out with every style.
If you've got a guy who's a kickboxer just doesn't have any ground game at all,
but he knocks motherfuckers senseless.
Find out if that guy can stand up.
Well,
that's what pride did with Berko Cro.
Cop Mirko Cro,
cop first flood,
Vandelay Silva.
He didn't have a fucking stitch of ground game.
He had nothing.
They would go to the ground.
He would just hang on for dear life and they got a 32nd rule and after 30
seconds in the ground,
they would stand it back up again and they would start kickbox again trying to
stay up.
They found out they threw him in there.
They find out.
That's part of the evolution of MMA and the evolution of MMA is still ongoing
because if a guy like Ben asking can dominate a guy like Doug Douglas Lema who
just smashes people in Bella towards beautiful knockouts,
Stryker,
I want to see what that guy can do against the very best in the world.
How the fuck does he deal with Tyron Woodley?
How's he deal with that unbelievable athlete,
that ridiculous superhero body that Tyron Woodley's got and ridiculous one punch
knockout power along the stream on your show.
I'm just,
I'm sitting here listening and I go,
wait,
I'm on the show.
I should say something.
I disagree.
Disagree with what?
I don't know.
I just want to stir you up.
I just think that,
I just think that you know you can't,
you can't change the rules because you don't like the results.
The results are unusual.
That's the thing about a guy like asking [inaudible] around and it was,
you know it what it Silva say,
you know,
25 minutes of one guy on top of another.
Okay,
what sport?
It's not true.
It's not true because you're always going to have people that don't fight like
that.
You're always going to have the v Two r Belfort's.
You always going to have the Chris Weidman's.
You're always going to have guys who win and don't win that way,
but that way is a way and if you deny that ways away you,
you cheapen the whole sport because you,
you throw this element into,
into the mix.
It's very effective.
You don't like the way it looks so you pull it out,
but it's still very effective.
It's still an effective element of fighting.
See,
you got to take the boring along with the good.
That's why I don't like stand ups.
If a guy can take you down a dry herb you for five rounds,
tough shit.
You got to figure out how to get up.
If that guy can hold you down and just punched you in the face or even just hold
you down,
you got to figure out a way to get up.
If you can't get up a referee coming long standing you up,
it's a legitimate,
I mean I'll say the referees are probably gonna stand a guy out.
Well I'll do that during commentary.
I'll do that because that's just the way they do it and that's part of the rules
and I'm doing commentary on a real thing.
But if I had my choice,
if they said to me,
what do you think?
Do you,
should we have stand ups?
Fuck no,
no standups,
no ever standups.
If a guide takes you down,
tough shit.
If he can hold you down for five minutes,
If you can hold you down for five minutes of every round tough shit,
that means you got to figure out how to not get taken down.
And when you get taken down,
you got to figure out how to get better again up.
You don't see that with some guys.
You don't see a,
a guy like Josie,
although getting taken down and held down because he can't do it.
You can't dig them down as you take them down,
you can't hold them down.
That's because he's the best.
And the guys who are the best,
you can't do that too.
And the guys who you can do that too.
Well,
they got to learn how to not get taken down and they got to learn how to not get
fucking mountain.
So it's like you're saying,
it's like a handicap in golf handicap.
You can't take away a guy's ability because you don't like the result because
the,
the abilities unusual.
And if you get it to a point where that guy is so good at that unusual ability
that he makes fights,
boring,
tough shit,
hope and pray for a man to come along the can solve it.
You know,
you,
we talk about this,
you talk about this,
Joe Silva talks about this sport,
um,
as if it's a hundred years old,
you know,
it's,
it's not been around.
That was almost a hundred.
Now it's 20.
It's getting there,
getting there,
getting there.
[inaudible] I gotta say this,
some of the years the development was,
uh,
um,
had been retarded a little bit,
a little bit,
you know,
99,
you know.
Well that's also my frustration when I,
when I quit.
Um,
it was,
uh,
when I quit the first version,
the UFC with a seg,
the UFC was in that weird state where it was a,
it was a paper view anymore or wasn't on cable,
was on direct.
There's on direct TV.
Only while I was on broadcast,
a lot of people don't know it was on Spanish,
uh,
broadcast channels because they were taking it an airing it while I was on FCC
broadcast.
Wow.
David Isaacs did that.
That's right.
I kind of remember that now.
I remember people were telling me,
cause you can see it now lay,
I think at midnight they were running it on,
I forget which.
I was probably the Univision channel here in La.
I think that,
uh,
did you do the tournament's?
I'm trying to remember.
No,
no,
I didn't do any of the tournament's Joan.
I was something,
man,
the tournaments were,
I mean that was just,
that was a different level.
I was involved in maybe wait a minute and now that I think about it,
there was like maybe one or two while I was involved in the first one,
the,
the heavyweight tournament with v tour.
I was involved with,
uh,
the,
my first one UFC 12 tournaments.
Yeah.
Vito or beat Trey tell him and then he beats got frozen and won the tournament.
And uh,
that was also the first heavyweight champion because that's when Mark Colon be
Dan Severn for the UFC heavyweight title.
So I was involved in that tournament,
that heavyweight tournament.
And there was a couple afterwards,
but then it broke down two weight classes.
Then guy stopped fighting more than once in a night,
which I think is also very intelligent.
Oh.
It was a crazy thing to do.
And I look back on it and then,
and I'm amazed at happened.
I'm amazed those guys did it.
There were so many things wrong with it.
You know,
like when someone was hurt and we have to put an alternate in that hadn't
happened earlier.
Fight,
you know,
it was just undoable.
It's unfair.
Unfair.
Those alternatively incredibly unfair.
You couldn't make it fit.
There wasn't,
there was no way to make it fair where I used to laugh and say,
okay,
if the alternates going in and we'll take them in the parking lot,
we'll have someone beat him up for two or three minutes and then put them in.
I mean,
there was no way to make it fair.
I don't think Gloria should do that either.
Gloria's still does tournaments and I think it's a huge mistake.
Oh,
they're really good.
Robinson boxing too,
you know,
they,
but they don't fight twice in a day in pro boxing.
No one,
no one has two fights in the night and pro boxing in Atlantic city a few years
ago.
Really?
Yeah.
And um,
and I forget who proposed it.
Laurie right now in America represents the highest level kickboxing absolutely
in the world.
And uh,
the w the United States has in the United States at least,
that we have access to.
And if you have the highest level kickboxing in the world and you have a
tournament format,
imagine if that was the case with boxing.
Could you imagine?
I mean,
could you imagine Floyd Mayweather and Canelo Alvarez fighting someone else
earlier in the day and then fighting each other?
Fuck that.
It's crazy.
That would never happen.
Crazy.
It's ridiculous.
And I think that's the thing you could chose to that tournament he was in,
what's the Bazooka Joe's Jovita Leni from uh Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Bazooka Joe and Ray Daniels.
Yeah.
That was great.
Josie Zuken Joe's in my show.
We brought him in to talk to the guy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Bad motherfucker.
He really is that ass kickboxer that fight with him and Raymond Daniels was
amazing cause Daniels has all these wild,
crazy flashy kicks and bought the [inaudible] just kept kicking the legs,
kicking the legs and chopped them down and then head kicked him.
It was classic Dutch style kickboxing Dutch style kickbox.
Yeah.
That was a great,
great fight.
But then Balta Laney went on after that hard fight and lost.
Yeah,
finals.
Disappointing.
From my point of view,
but,
but because he had a hard fight,
I mean a too,
too hard fights in a day.
That's crazy.
And then a lot of time off in between the fight.
You know what I think it did back in the UFC is early days and it's very
different now.
But we didn't have a reality show,
we didn't have social media.
There was no way to get to know the fighters.
And if you saw a man fight a couple of fights in a night,
you really did feel like you knew him.
You saw him tested in
a couple of different ways.
You saw his heart,
you saw his stamina,
you saw his style because the style started to break down pretty much unless you
were at Gracie.
So I think it was a way to really tell a story about somebody in a one night and
by the end of the tournament you were,
you were rooting for one of the two guys.
That's a good point.
You know,
it's just,
I don't think it's a good idea as far as,
I'm not advocating the health and safety factor,
but I agree with you that there was a spectacle factor to it that was quite
interesting.
It was really kind of exciting.
The fact that,
you know,
voice would beat this guy and then,
the hoist had faced that guy later and you know,
and if he beats him,
he gets to the finals.
Like all those,
those tournament things were fun.
It was fun to track and follow.
We pulled the names out of a hat too.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Well it's crazy now when you look back at it now and you know,
you go to these events,
like whether it's UFC 100 or one of the new ones,
like this weekend,
Ronda Rousey versus Sarah McMahon and,
and you're there in Vegas and there's 15,000 people screaming at the top of
their lungs and standing on their feet.
What does it feel like?
Do you feel,
do you have a sense of pride that you're a part of this?
Absolutely.
And I'll tell you,
but,
and I don't mean that pride.
Not in the sense that I had anything to do with those live events because when I
was doing at our live events suck so bad.
It was unbelievable.
They were so bad.
And,
but prof course pride,
you know,
I mean Joe,
I know how much it's changed and I hear how much,
you know,
but it's still the octagon.
It's still you.
It's still Joe Silva,
you know,
out Connell still producing.
Right.
I mean it's kind of that creative thing that I put together.
So in feel,
it's like going to a high school reunion.
You know,
I,
that's what I felt like it 20th I recognized every,
you know,
I recognized everybody,
I used herb dean in the iron ring to sign herb and big John and you know,
and it's like that this is the group that I did.
It's very,
very different.
You know,
it's very different,
but it's also the same,
you know,
it's also the same.
So I have a great deal of pride,
not claiming credit for that.
But I do think,
you know,
I think maybe another,
bringing in silver,
bringing in you sorta like help create the DNA of the UFC.
And another thing,
you know,
bringing in the wrestlers,
when it looked like voice was going to win everything.
And I reached out to Dan Severin and Mark Schultz who was the first Olympic gold
medalists to be in the UFC.
Severin you know,
these guys came in Coleman,
you know,
they came in to sort of challenge and I think that helps set up the DNA of,
of the UFC to the big college wrestlers.
Mark Schultz was a beast man.
A lot of people don't know and fight on,
what was it,
like eight days days or something.
And you know,
I called his brother Dave,
you know who,
who was murdered by the dupont air,
if anyone remembers.
Yeah.
Horrible,
horrible story.
I called him originally because I want,
he was bigger.
I wanted him to do it and he goes,
ah,
that sounds crazy.
You should call my brother.
He'll fight right in there.
Well,
he,
uh,
he wound up having to
quit his MMA career because he was a wrestling coach and because of his,
uh,
whereas at Byu is that,
I think that was that wherever he was a wrestling coach,
he,
they didn't want him doing anything with this cage fighting stuff.
So it was the opposite problem you had with news radio that yeah,
exactly.
Well,
it was one of those things where I think he was,
um,
you know,
he was in a position where it wasn't going to make any money,
and the way to make money as a wrestler,
as to get a coaching Gig and when you're an elite wrestler,
like he,
he had a real serious staph infection to where I almost lost his arm.
Really,
really bad staph infection where he is this huge,
I wonder if there's a picture of them.
There's a huge scar that he had on his arm that like
all the way up in system,
the nerve Murcia Nerissa fleshing Murcia yeah.
Well,
it's not flesh eating.
It's different than that.
It's just a very strong form of staph infection.
Yeah.
You know,
what impressed me about him?
He was fight ready.
He,
you know,
he was in fight level condition,
walking around.
You know,
he'd never was not like that.
That's why I could take that fight and be very secure and well,
a guy like that,
his wrestling is so God damn good.
You're just knocking.
Stop.
Sound is fat.
And he does.
I look,
is it distracting to look at yourself?
We'll shut the camera angle.
It's that angle.
Emphasizing my girth.
Listen,
my white layer.
You look beautiful.
You've been around.
Do you know Ariel Helwani?
Sure.
You see a nice guy.
Very nice guy.
He doesn't seem to know me.
What do you mean?
Well,
he confused me with Art Davey the last time I was on the show.
How rude and you know,
and I love art,
but I can tell us apart.
You look different.
Yeah.
We looked different.
You and are very different.
Yeah.
I don't have a hat.
He uh,
he went anti UFC for awhile,
right?
Yeah.
Didn't he?
After he got fired,
he got angry and was saying a bunch of shit.
He wrote a letter,
he wrote an open letter to John Mccain saying,
you know,
you're kind of right.
Yeah.
It wasn't that.
And Art,
if you're listening,
that was wrong.
My man,
you should've called me.
Jasmine was,
yeah,
that was kind of a punk.
[inaudible] a good guy.
What happened?
He just didn't get along with you guys anymore.
Gone at that point.
Right?
When did you leave?
What event did you leave at?
Why?
I was consulting in Epping through like 20 2122.
But you know,
I think of the first 12 is mine.
Right.
And because of the concepts were mind,
you know,
we were doing themes,
David versus Goliath and you know,
stuff like that.
So I think the first 12 you know,
Jesus had 12 disciples.
You know,
I had 12.
Uh,
but you know,
UFC is,
um,
wow.
I hope that's totally the same.
I mean,
that's hard.
That's hard.
Wow.
12 steps.
You know,
I'm just thinking of 1212 staff people.
I apologize and did not mean any comparison between me and you Christ.
I way didn't,
it was just jokes.
It was 12.
It was a dozen.
It was a dozen,
like a Baker's dozen.
So,
uh,
you know,
but I think I was trying to find,
um,
always something to promote,
you know,
back then again,
no social media,
no internet,
you know,
no budgets.
We always have to have some hook.
And it,
I,
to me,
it had to be fun or I didn't want to do it.
And,
uh,
you know,
on Joe Silva says,
famous,
you know,
this quote,
uh,
the worst thing that would happen to the UFC is if it became a sport that gets
attributed to me.
You know,
it's Joe Silva that's actually been saying,
I said that,
I don't actually remember seeing that.
You probably said that.
He just forgot you said.
Of course.
I said it just remembers John Perretti.
How'd you get involved with John Brewer like John?
Yeah,
I found him creepy.
Why was the creepy?
I just,
he creeped me out.
In what way?
In the creepy way.
[inaudible] John,
I'm sorry.
You're a great guy for your listening.
He listened.
I don't know.
You're gonna find out.
He,
uh,
sent me a tweet once asked,
which is creepy why I never had him on a show.
Why won't have him on his show?
Cause he's creepy.
It was a weird tweet.
He goes,
uh,
you know,
I can't believe you won't have me on my show.
Uh,
I,
uh,
always respected you when we hired you.
And I go,
oh,
when he hired you,
he was nowhere.
We just said,
we may not,
here's why I think I don't like him.
Uh,
extremely challenging fighting or whatever the penthouse version was.
They totally fucked it up,
you know?
And that was Bob Gucci own and I think that same challenge.
Right.
What else?
Room fighting,
fighting Lee,
extreme challenge,
good fights,
whatever it was.
Yeah,
they did have a couple of,
you know,
and I had some good fighters and Peretti I think was doing the matchmaking,
but a Gucci only son and announced that he was going to do extremely extreme
fighting in Madison Square Garden.
And that's what made Giuliani crazy.
And that's what made everybody crazy in New York.
He announced he was coming to the garden,
you know,
we were going to go back upstate again to buffalo.
You remember?
You know,
but they announced they were doing the garden and Giuliani went on in my city.
I draw the line in the face of tyranny or you know,
I mean,
Giuliani fought the mafia.
He's like running down to try to hold up,
you know,
the world trade centers during nine 11 Giuliani.
He's not scared of anyone.
So when you piss him off,
you got to get off that bus man,
and you've got to go take another bus and you've got to get out of town and
extremely extreme fighting.
You know,
they were,
they,
they were rubbing,
you know,
look,
I went pretty far.
That was too far.
Don't piss off.
Rudy Giuliani did the mafia.
So how did Peretti wind up going from extreme fighting to the UFC?
What happened there?
It was someone's bright idea,
not mine.
So,
and then he came over and was doing commentary for the UFC or just matchmaking?
I think it was never match making commentary.
I think he was doing a little camera work.
I don't know.
I'm trying to remember.
I know he did commentary,
fixed her hair and makeup for some of the guys.
I know he did commentary for extreme fighting.
I want to say,
just want to say John,
there's no,
if you see me on the
street to beat the shit out of me and it wouldn't mean it wouldn't mean anything
to you.
You could kick my ass.
Why are you worried that he would do that?
Is He that kind of outrageous stuff?
I don't really know him.
You're not really saying anything that outrageous.
I'm trying to find out what you don't like.
We don't really established that I have a bad memory,
but I'm very creative.
You have a bad memory,
but you're adamant about fucking getting pissed off to do with extremely extreme
fighting.
Then you're really screwed it up for the UFC.
You really hurt the UFC so you shouldn't,
you know,
you know.
Well,
I don't think it was their life to Japan and do k three or whatever it was.
You wanted to do it.
If it was their idea,
they didn't want to get that press release.
They were not real.
They were oppressed.
20 talking about there's some good fights.
There was Mark Coleman or um,
uh,
Conan,
Sylvia.
When was I,
you know,
county,
you couldn't,
not Mari Smith at Maurice Smith kick was the first head kicks in MMA.
But you know,
Maurice Smith was one of those.
Yeah,
it was a little bit like the Dutch kickboxers fought everywhere and just kept
going.
Professional fighter.
Yeah.
It was always,
always gave a good show.
Never gave a great job.
Gracie Gracie fall with a wedding ring on,
punched the dude in the face with a wedding ring on.
You remember that?
Yes.
The bare knuckle days,
man,
that was,
uh,
that was a Mario Sperry.
Mario very first fought MMA.
Igor is Novia Mario last eagle refers Enovia but its first loss.
She knew and she was lost.
You and Bruce back.
I just literally remember everything.
I remember a lot when it comes to MMA,
I get,
it jogs my memory when you say it,
but if you'd asked me that before you said it,
I couldn't,
I couldn't come up with,
well,
I don't have any other sports in their clogging them up the pores.
I don't know.
Basketball,
baseball will soak up all your memory.
Yeah.
Stats.
Right.
That's all those stats.
They can just get chiseled in those spaces and nooks and crannies of your mind.
There's no work.
There's no room in there for the eagles and Novia of crossing Gracie Jr,
you know all that shit.
Yeah,
man.
There was some,
despite her tattoos,
I remember the tattoos were bad.
Gary Myers,
Gary the iron bear Myers,
remember him?
Gary Myers,
holy crap.
Heavyweight and he was like five,
eight built like a fucking brick shithouse you notes,
man.
That's something.
It's like the guys,
the physiques now are very different.
Right?
It's much more,
um,
there's a,
there's a similarity to the guys and I don't mean that in any bad way,
but it's a,
you know,
it's like you see the specialized form in the NFL,
the different positions have different forums and the UFC has sort of taken that
on,
you know,
in some ways.
Yeah,
there's Gary Myers in some ways it has,
but in other ways,
I mean one of the guys I brought up earlier,
a Tyron Woodley,
Tyron Woodley's built like a fucking superhero.
He doesn't look like an MMA fighter and a lot of ways he's so big and muscular,
he kind of looks like almost like too big for Mna yet he's fighting at the
highest level and he fighting Carlos Condit next in Dallas.
And a great fight into really interesting because content is built like more of
your standard MMA fighters,
lean tall,
long guy with you know,
good musculature but nothing crazy.
Whereas Woodley's just as fucking beast and Carlos condit has shown that he can
go five rounds,
go five rounds against GSP and still have endurance in the fifth and final
round.
So it's going to be interesting to see,
look at Tyron Woodley,
look at the building or not Christ,
that's a fucking athlete right there.
That guy's unbelievable.
Like the fast and powerful.
Well,
he's still a little bit thicker than your average boxer,
but yeah,
I could see some boxers being built like that.
Just it's not unusual for everything.
There's that better cardio than the Yam.
No,
they make no chance.
No Way.
Close.
Not even close.
I think MMA is superior.
Fuck yeah.
I'm by 1000%
say that they are above a boxer.
Yes.
They all limbic.
Rest.
You have to do more.
It's harder.
It's harder to control a guy's body than it is to move your own body in and out
and around a guy.
When you're controlling the other guy's body and grappling and pushing and
tussling with them,
they break it up quickly.
And that's the reason why Muhammad Ali,
who was so intelligent used to lean on guys when he got him in the clip.
But DOPA.
Yeah.
But when no,
he,
when he got him in the clinch,
he would lean on guys backs and their next,
he would pull them down and lean on him.
A lot of fighters do that.
Bernard Hopkins famous for that.
He leans on those guys.
That shit wears you out.
It wears you out,
it slows you down.
It's the same reason why George Saint Pierre did that to Bj Penn when they first
fought the first fight or the first round of their second fight grabs a hold of
Bj pushes up against the cage.
It turns into a wrestling match.
The more you can keep BJ wrestling,
the more he's going to exhaust him.
But if you're just standing around with them kickbox with a moving in and out,
it's way easier to kickbox.
It's way easier to box.
You're only controlling your own body.
You're moving your own body back and forth and around.
But as soon as you got to move and guy's body and he tries to move you when
you're trying to counter him moving you,
that Shit's exhausting.
You didn't you as usual,
you're right.
But I think in any fight,
the change,
the adrenaline has changed in your body takes its toll.
The focus.
Anytime you're in a fight,
I believe humans,
you know,
fight or flight,
we are made to run away or made to fight.
And I think when you're in a fight,
professional amateur bar when you're in the focus is,
is what becomes really challenging.
The ability to stay that focus to protect yourself or to attack.
And I think that's also what wears people down.
You know?
And I think that in boxing you're,
you're exactly right.
MMA,
there's so many variables,
so much happening,
you know,
you're going to wear yourself out.
But that focus and boxing I think is very,
very wearing for those guys.
Oh for sure.
To be a target for that long is wearing certainly
it certainly wearing,
that's the,
but that exist in MMA as well.
Um,
the other thing is the five rounds or five minute rounds,
five minute rounds is a big difference.
To do three minutes boxing as opposed to do five minutes of grappling is a big
fucking difference.
I think the amount that they have to train is different as well.
Like boxers,
oftentimes we'll just trained once a day and maybe they'll run in the morning or
get a little bit a strength and conditioning workout in the morning
and then they'd do their boxing at night.
With MMA fighters,
it's often to really hard workouts a day or three sometimes.
And when you're talking about three means that that's just unbelievably taxing
on the body.
Unbelievable.
It's one of the reasons why there's so much of a performance enhancing drug
problem and m m m m m a and hear more about it,
but you hear more about it.
Then you get hear about an Inbox,
first sport to test for HIV borne disease disease.
We were the first,
you don't want a guy mounting you with the aids.
Not In the cock fighting.
No.
Yeah.
You don't want that.
That's smart.
What,
what year was it?
Is that,
what did you guys do?
This was nicely scam.
Yes,
we did.
I love the admitted.
That's huge.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
that's probably a good thing to test for.
You know,
it's funny,
in my,
my,
my son works for the Manhattan da and they do this big charity boxing thing.
So my son was a baseball player and a high school and a little bit in college
and he's got gotten into boxing for this charity thing they're doing.
And he's,
he's a good athlete and in pretty good shape,
play soccer,
you know,
plays a lot of sports,
whipped from the boxing,
whipped from the boxing workouts he's doing.
You know,
it's really,
um,
you know,
fighting is a very different thing.
We talk about this,
you know,
Joe,
I've got to say,
we all,
we want to talk about this.
Like it's a sport because I think it brings a certain dignity to the athletes.
It brings a certain sanctity of the events and it brings a certain advertiser
into the process.
So it's important to talk about this as a sport,
but you know,
it is a fight.
These are fights and that's why it's different,
you know?
And that's when you talked about that,
uh,
electric atmosphere.
It's a fight,
you know?
And that holy shit moment that Lorenzo described it is a fight.
And I think what we're doing here in,
in promoting this is,
you know,
I've got to say,
I may take crap for this.
I think it's a good thing because I think people need this sort of escape
mechanism,
you know?
And I do think martial artists and even,
you know,
most boxers,
even though boxing has become such a ghetto,
I sport in some ways,
you know,
but I think the way these fighters conduct themselves and what they have to go
through and what they face and going into,
whether it's the octagon or a loud,
you know,
I,
there's,
there's an inherent dignity in this because it's a fight,
not in spite of it being a fight.
You know,
this is a real challenge.
I remember Ken shamrock had fought all over the world,
one of the real professional fighters in the early days,
right?
He,
you know,
he'd fought in Japan.
He fought all over the world.
He said,
when he went into the octagon,
in that steel door,
went behind him.
He said that was an oh shit moment for him,
you know,
and that guy had been around,
and I think I,
I agree with this being categorized as a sport,
but in some ways it transcend sport too.
You know,
because I don't know.
Football's a tough sport,
but I,
I don't think it's the same as going into the octagon.
Yeah,
it's a different thing
if you lose,
you know,
if the ball gets past you,
it's not that big a deal.
Well,
it's not,
you just,
you might lose,
you might feel bad,
but you're not gonna feel bad.
Like a guy beats your ass for God gets on top of your,
mounts you and punches your face until you lean over and tap the mat or go
unconscious or the referee rescues you.
That's humiliating that you eat,
that guys stole something from you.
There's mean,
so many people have said it in so many flamboyant ways,
but essentially he takes a piece of your manhood.
It tastes,
it takes a piece of what it is to be a man.
And people don't want to admit that.
But the reality is you become less attractive to women.
You know,
you,
you do.
If a guy kicks your ass,
you become,
instead of people admiring you,
they feel pity for you.
It's a completely different result than if you win.
Try takes,
takes away elemental and you work six weeks for that man.
You work six weeks and you still got fucked up.
You did your best,
you did all your training,
you put in all your time,
you drank water.
He didn't have any beer.
He didn't fuck.
He did all these things that you're supposed to do and you still got fucked up.
Rhonda,
you know,
says the opposite about fucking,
well,
she doesn't have a Dick Hollow.
Yeah.
Is a big weekend.
You know that.
Yeah.
When you shoot in loans,
you're uh,
you're getting rid of things.
You have to rebuild.
You know,
I'm glad you explained that to me.
I hadn't really felt you didn't know that
back to the cock fighting.
It all comes back to the cocktail.
Well,
this weekend is the first time ever in the history of the UFC.
Two Olympic medalists are going at it and they just so happen to be women.
That's incredible.
It's beyond incredible.
That's amazing.
And it's,
it's perfect that it's Rhonda and Sara McMann because they're two very different
worlds.
Deserve it.
Yes.
Do you know what?
I think that's another thing the UFC does,
you know,
it gives a professional level two Olympic in college wrestling that didn't exist
unless you want it to go have Vince Mcmahon's,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
dramas.
Yeah.
I,
it turned,
it turned wrestling into a professional sport.
Again,
wrestling used to be a professional sport.
You know,
long time ago.
It's very different.
Uh,
you know,
now it's theater,
but you know,
back in the day,
actually guys,
you know,
we're real wrestlers and wrestled is going back 30,
40,
50 years.
Right.
So I think what the UFC did is give a group of athletes or a career trajectory,
you know,
where it was an Olympic judo guy going to go.
Right.
I'll teach.
That's it.
Same with the wrestlers.
Yeah.
It's really shocking to me that there's professional avenues for things like
tennis,
but there's no professional avenues for wrestling.
I find wrestling to be very exciting there is in the UFC,
that's the bad,
but it's not because then they have to punch and they have to kick and they have
to,
you know,
they have to worry about head trauma.
There's,
there's a lot of new skills that they have to learn.
They have to learn submissions.
It's kind of amazing.
They're wrestling didn't become a professional sport and it's really one of
those factors of promotion.
It was never promoted correctly that real wrestling never,
or maybe it's back to my original point that of guys are going to roll around on
the ground all the time and your franchise decides to do something about that.
That maybe makes it more exciting because in wrestling it is rolling around on
the ground and I,
and I think,
you know,
it's trying to take each other down.
It's battling those [inaudible]
ground.
Yeah.
You can only win on the ground.
And so the sport is a matte sport.
That's one of the years.
Right.
You know,
you know this,
you know right here.
And I do.
And I think,
you know,
there's still,
I don't know what it is,
whether it was boxing or whatever it is,
where it's ingrained in us that you want to see guys fight at least some of the
time standing up.
I think the UFC,
you know,
it has added to,
the change in what we think of fight looks like without a doubt.
But you still want to see guys stand up and you know,
even the wrestlers at some point want to prove they can do that too.
Hmm.
Maybe.
But uh,
I mean I think ultimately MMA is always going to be the most exciting form of
combat sports cause it's everything combined.
But no argument here,
my friend.
But I love kickboxing.
I love boxing and I love Jujitsu.
I will love to,
I would pay without a doubt to see worldclass professional Jujitsu guys like
chalk arrayed,
guys like Marcella Garcia just going at it.
Submission,
grappling.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're in a very elite group.
You know,
you're in a very efficient [inaudible],
you know,
very high end group.
Okay.
Do you know who?
I'd still think people watch tennis.
Who gives a fuck of that ball goes across that net.
I don't give a shit.
People,
people watching us,
thousands of people in the stands,
millions around the world.
Watch something that's on its best day is not nearly as exciting as a Marcello
Garcia strangulation.
Marcello Garcia takes you back and get those hooks in and got out.
Highlight that quote that let's pull up Marcello Garcia versus victor versus
Shaolin Victor Shaolin
he borrowed.
While he's doing that,
you know what big John said to me?
He said,
MMA is the best sport for women to do because if you watch women's basketball,
you watch women's tennis.
The upper body strength is obviously lacking in those sports.
MMA leverage skill more below the hill,
you know,
below the waist and the legs are important.
Yeah,
watch this shit.
What's it look at this arm.
Drag Lucas a spin to the back.
Come on son.
And then his strangulation.
Not only that,
he's doing it to a world class Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt,
and he puts them out fucking cold.
Look at this.
You tell me.
That's not exciting.
I'll tell you this.
I'm fucking wrong with you.
Look at that night night sun,
Marcella Garcia Bitch mean.
You can argue then who the fuck would not want to watch them on television?
You just need more guys like that.
How long was that?
It was 15 seconds.
I was going to say 20 savings.
Watch it again.
Watch it again when he takes his back.
This is,
this is a technique and this is,
there's beauty in this.
People can look back up all the way back,
all the way back,
all the way back.
Although it back,
watch how he like takes his back.
Watch his arm,
drag the left hand to his right hand,
right hand and the arm pit spins,
takes the back,
keeps going,
keeps spinning and keeps Ben and keeps bending,
keeps bending.
Shalon tries to recover.
The arm goes underneath the chin.
He tries to get you even get them on the side.
He's not even fully like locked in with both hooks in.
He's almost in a half guard with a rear naked and puts him
out.
If you don't think that that would be exciting on TV.
Every match was like that,
but they don't have to be all like that.
It's the potential for that is what makes you pull one up from memory.
It was exactly as you described it.
You did great commentary.
I'm in awe,
but just like what I'm saying with baseball,
if every time a guy went to bat,
he hit a home run,
then it would be much more exciting.
Right?
So let's make people throw the ball slower.
Let's make the or the nineties with steroids.
But even then it never happened.
No one's ever done that.
So like every fight can't be knockouts with kickboxing.
Every fight that you see in a Jujitsu match can't be Marcella Garcia strangling
absolute.
But it's the potential for those amazing moments that make the dull spots more
important.
Um,
you know,
you raise a great point.
Um,
but let me ask you this because now I'm looking for a new audience and maybe an
audience that literally would not understand what you just said.
Not just because they,
they don't speak English,
they do speak English,
but just because they don't have the background.
I mean,
your background's phenomenal.
They can't even come to your party.
They're not even on the wait list to get into what you're talking about.
So how,
how does UFC grow?
How does MMA grow?
Is it bringing more of a highly,
you know,
when you go to,
you said you weren't a baseball fan.
I know you're from Boston.
I played baseball when I was a kid.
I found martial arts.
I wasn't busy.
So you go to,
you go to Fenway,
you go to Yankee stadium,
the crowd knows what's happening,
right?
But if you go the Marlins game,
you know there's places where you go and the fans clearly not into the baseball
as much.
Right?
So I think the UFC is it,
um,
I don't know if it's a,
it's not a crucial point for the UFC at all.
UFC is doing great,
but how do you reach a new audience?
How do you spread out your calling up fights?
When was that fight?
When that was thousand three,
11 fucking years ago,
Joe.
And you're calling that up from memory and it exactly is what you were talking
about.
How do we reach a new audience that can't do that,
that say someone has 1000th of your knowledge and that's probably still more
than what a lot of people have,
right?
How are we going to reach him?
How are we going to tell them about this sport?
Well,
you don't have to,
they don't have to know what I know to enjoy it.
You know what I am is what,
you know,
what I represent proudly is the hardcore fan.
I get to talk,
I'm the hardcore fan that gets to talk and I,
that's one of the reasons why I still post on mixed martial arts.com.
I still,
you know,
have a combat sports forum on my own message board.
I'm,
you're on the underground cause I always see Logan reads this.
So Joe it all the time.
I
read it every day.
And I think that that's important that I,
I take great pride in the fact that I represent those guys,
those fucking savages,
those,
those are my people.
And um,
but do,
you don't have to tribe.
Yeah,
but you don't have to be me.
You know,
if someone just a casual person could appreciate fighting because it's you,
you just watching it,
it's exciting watching that.
You didn't have to be able to call that arm draw,
dragged to the back and point out that he's choking them out from actually a
half guard position almost.
It doesn't matter.
You're still knowing what's going on.
If you know it's a choke and it's exciting.
Look,
UFC one,
Denver,
Colorado,
mcnichols arena,
you know what I read in the New York Times was talking about how the UFC was
started on the edges of the fringes of society.
And you know,
my office was at Park Avenue and 57th street,
you know,
Bertelsmann one of the biggest media companies in the world owned the company.
John Millie has helped create,
you know,
it was ridiculous.
And you know,
we were in mcnichols arena,
which you're very famous,
you know,
big arena.
And so we're there and it's hoist versus um,
the assassin.
What Gerard Gordo and cause I think he really wasn't assassin,
you know,
cause he just had that look and uh,
they do the fight and hoists gets them on the ground and it's,
he does his pies and thing that gets in and he chokes on many taps.
And Damn Front there's a,
there's a gentleman,
and I don't know if he actually was a pimp,
maybe he was a pimp,
but he had a,
a one of those full end fur coats.
And he did have a purple hat with a feather in it.
And he did have two women on each side of him and the women,
I'm not saying they were prostitutes,
but they certainly could play a prostitute in a movie with what they were
wearing.
Right.
And so they're watching,
watching a voice chokes him unconscious into,
or he taps,
he doesn't go unconscious and the pimps stands or the guy stands up and he goes,
somebody
bullshit.
I've seen two hoes fight
better than that.
And,
you know,
and I busted God,
I go,
you know,
I,
I don't want to say I have to,
cause I can't really say if I've seen two hose fight.
But you know,
I knew I took his point.
And I think you've got to remember that joke is we're going forward with this
sport.
It's hard.
It's hard to come to the UFC for 54 95 and try it out.
Right.
And it's hard to turn on the TV and this is,
you know,
I really do love you and I admire you and I respect you.
And I did,
you know,
and that's why I wanted you in the UFC and I figured you could,
sort of save it.
That's why you sorta came in and,
but I think that there's a whole group of people when they turn on,
they go,
what the fuck
and what is that guy talking about?
Did you ever think that I was going to save it?
First of all,
I definitely did.
If you've said about it,
the UFC,
the dark ages and it was the most disorganized.
Yeah.
Why did you think that bringing in the comedian can in some some ways because
Comedians,
a Dj's are professional talkers,
professional
talkers.
We needed a professional talker.
You had a great persona,
you had a great look.
You look the part,
you know,
uh,
you're,
you're much more buff now,
but you looked apart back then when Ann,
I thought you were going to be the guy that was going to try to figure it out
and explain it to people.
And if you had to do time,
remember in a comedy club when someone did this,
you could do that,
right?
I know you could stretch,
So I knew you were going to be able to do that.
And to me it was a really good move.
You know,
it was a,
it was a very strong move to give a public face,
a persona in front of the UFC that wasn't talking about human cockfighting and
why it was really okay and were really nice guys.
You could go out and just pump the shit out of it.
You weren't apologizing for anything.
You,
you were really,
you were,
you were the perfect guy for the job,
Joe.
You really were.
There wasn't anyone else.
I would have rather had honest to God.
Well that's,
I guess I'm pro,
I'm proven right.
Well,
you were,
you were a ahead of your time.
I just thought it was going to be just this ridiculous job that I would keep for
a short amount of time.
Oh,
I could had Jay more for that.
Ah,
Jay.
Um,
when you're compared to,
you know,
there's comparisons between,
you,
there's a similarity and you may not like to hear this.
You're both tough guys and your persona.
Stop right there.
Back Up.
Erase your words.
Washing mouth.
I would say get the fuck out of here.
I want your audience to know what balls I have to said that on Joe.
Show to a job and you're a three and a half feet away.
Are you,
um,
when you watch the UFC today,
what,
if anything,
would you change?
Nothing.
You don't think there's anything that needs to be fixed?
Rules wise.
What about the 12 to six elbow?
That's some ridiculous shit.
You know,
you can't do that.
everything in context,
everything is in context.
It's not coming out of thin air.
Things are the way they are because over the course of 20 years,
I think Dana and Lorenzo and you and Joe,
you don't have figured out the best,
I don't want to say compromise because compromise is a word that it implies.
You're not doing your best,
but you,
you all have found the best way to promote this as a sport and yet still have,
it's still a fight.
It's still crazy.
It's still a fight.
GSP fight.
That was our fight,
man.
I was sick.
That was,
that was a fight.
I was a full on fight.
You know,
and you know,
and so when I see that,
and there's a lot of UFC now,
there's a lot of UFC,
so there's going to be somewhat of a variety of quality and know the fights just
cause that's how it is.
There's a lot of baseballs,
summer,
great games,
some aren't.
But I think the consistent level,
the UFC is what impresses me.
I mean it's generally always good.
Do you think it's good to have one predominant mixed martial arts country
company?
Do you think?
As long as it's a UFC,
yes.
Anyone else that go monopoly Scott.
And now it's the UFC.
Everybody else pack up your bags and go home.
Just leave.
Just get out of the business.
What do you mean it's the UFC you mean?
So you don't think that like a company like Bella Tor is legitimate or
important?
No,
I don't really important to who?
For what?
For fighters.
For Spike.
Maybe while for fighters,
for providers to have other venues.
I am sure that if there were no other franchises that there would be a system
put in place by the UFC to not,
to,
to totally utilize the talent that's gone.
Then aspirin.
I like them a lot.
Good luck at one FC.
Eddie Alvarez.
Eddy is,
I really like Eddie.
Michael Chandler,
Chandler,
another one.
Yeah,
there's good fighters,
but there's only one UFC.
I mean you've got a sprinkling of good fighters elsewhere,
but the other franchises,
they're lame.
They're just lame.
Well,
um,
I think,
and you know,
they're lame.
Why don't think their lane,
but you don't want to say it because anybody goes,
oh,
he's a shill for the UFC truth.
Truth is truth.
Okay.
I don't think Bella Tours lame.
I don't really know.
I can't even follow the tournament.
You know my tournaments,
good fight.
Three hours.
My tournament was in three hours.
Their tournaments are like three months.
I don't even remember.
They're doing it the right way.
They're not having people fight more than once a night.
I think that's a good thing.
I think your tournaments out who won,
I think your tournament's that we did were traits that have nothing to do with
the tournament's in everything to do with who they just signed.
Right.
That's true.
So that's kind of bullshit.
Well that is a little weird,
but they should be able to do that.
I bled.
No,
go on rock fan.
I'm not necessarily a fan of the tournament form,
which is better.
Bellator,
UFC,
UFC.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's my point.
But I still watch it.
I still watch Bella to our fights.
I look forward series of fighting Eddie Alvarez and um,
and Michael Chandler.
That was a great rock and fight.
That second fight in the first five.
Both of them were granted once.
You'd be good too.
Why would you not want to watch that?
I do want to Jimmy Smith,
the guy who does my job in the UFC is great.
He's,
in my opinion,
he's one of the best in the world that he's an MMA comment too.
I think he's really good.
He knows his shit.
He knows his shit when it comes to striking and knows.
He knows the transitions and the ground.
He knows when,
when a guys in danger,
he knows when a guy's okay.
He's,
he's,
but he doesn't seem like he's gonna explode.
You seem to be red lining from the moment the camera goes on.
It's like red light,
red light.
Yeah.
Well that's intense man.
No,
it's you.
That's me.
Well,
when I like when we first did fox,
the first thing they were talking in my ear telling me to calm down,
take it down a notch.
And I'm just like,
I can't believe anybody is telling me to take it down a notch.
Like they wanted it to be,
fuck sports,
this is what's going on tonight.
Junior dos Santos out of Brazil.
And um,
you know,
I'm like two men enter several steps ahead of that and red in the neck.
My veins are pumping out and I'm ready to fucking explode and I'm excited for
real legitimately,
you know,
so I don't think they liked,
that's what I like about it.
That's why I think that's why again,
it's,
it is a sport and uh,
but it's more,
it's a sport of fighting.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the purest example,
the purest expression of competition.
What would any likes board about is whether it's basketball,
you know,
that's fixed.
Basketball is two men competing to try to do a specific goal to get their ball
into a hole.
But it's just,
they're competing through this metaphor.
No,
we're talking about basketball.
I said basketball,
basketball's and basketball game,
which you play against gravity.
That's what basketball and other people that are playing against you.
But the dominance of another man by slam dunking a ball in his face,
it doesn't mean much.
It's only,
it only means something because you choose to that cock fighting thing.
What she teaches dominating people when you,
when a guy balls in their faces.
Oh,
I said we slam dunk a ball.
That's what I said.
You getting a little,
I need more of the boat too hard.
We are out of it.
That's it.
We drank it all.
You can't,
you can't drink too much wine.
Have you have a heart attack on the show?
Too much caffeine is not.
Is that good for our ratings?
Can I plug my Twitter Joe?
Everyone said my,
my Twitter is embarrassing.
Dana has 2.8 million.
I haven't started out your fucking,
you've had at Twitter for a week.
How long have you had Twitter for?
Um,
my daughter helped me put it up,
I think Tuesday.
Yeah.
Come on man.
Look,
how much did you have when you started this show?
207 now you got 482 so what I'm talking about sambo combined today.
Come on.
C a m p.
Don't talk while I'm trying to plug your fucking Twitter man.
He's crazy about it.
This
Campbell combat,
they see I work alone.
Usually go,
oh my gosh,
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
Oh my God.
C A M p.
B e l l c o m.
B.
A.
T.
E Campbell combined.
Tay,
why didn't you just go with Campbell Mclaren?
Did somebody already have that?
I didn't think of that.
Jesus Christ.
What if this fucking show gets canceled then you're still stuck with this
combined yet.
I'm getting off Twitter.
I don't want to hear from these
kids.
Say that you can say that you fucking,
you,
you're tanking your whole operation online to social media thing.
Right off the bat.
No,
I gotta be me.
You got you gotta be you.
I appreciate that man.
I appreciate that.
What else you got going on?
I'm,
you know,
I'm really focused on this,
uh,
combined day.
America's,
I like it a lot.
It's the first.
It's the thing,
you know,
it,
it sounds cliche.
I'm as excited about it as I was 20 years ago.
It's cool because there's a bunch of people that I go MMA,
they go,
is that,
what is that?
I mean they really ask that.
I have to bring this up because this is one of my favorite stories that you ever
told me.
Oh No.
Ron Van Cleef.
Oh,
what a fucker.
Me Or him?
Not You.
No,
no.
You gotta tell me which you go.
Tell me what it was like first he came to the office.
I'm thankfully it came to the office with disciples dragon with disciples.
This is an insult to say,
tell me how,
tell me the whole story.
Is there,
is there a picture of him?
Help Inspire Jamie.
We'll pull one up.
Ron.
You Know Ron van Cleef is a weird guy,
right?
I mean it feels weird guy.
Uh,
I think he was 50 when he came into the UFC five.
Oh,
maybe even 51.
Yeah.
Cause he came in and he said,
um,
and then we were,
I forget which one it was,
would've been six
was uh,
yeah,
it was somewhere in,
he had some other involvement with the UFC before that,
correct?
No,
he did the fight and then he became the commissioner.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
so he came in,
he said he was going to do the,
um,
the New York City Marathon.
I go,
all right,
finish that.
And I forget.
You know,
I set a time,
finish that and then we'll talk.
But the last thing I wanted was some 50 year old guy.
You don't have them fucking die talking about UFC.
I mean,
that,
that's not even like good for the buy rate.
Yeah.
Pull up the video of him.
His fight against hoists.
Gracie rundown please.
He fights getting lots of doubt.
God did luck out that he fought Tracy.
Right.
The voice.
Yeah.
You know,
and voices that gentleman,
he didn't want to hurt the old guy.
Well,
Ron van Cleef was a legit karate fighter.
There's some really good footage of him fighting.
He was,
he was very fast.
He was a real karate guy.
I think he did a lot for,
you know,
say the community.
He,
he helped inspire poor kids at a time when,
you know,
in the sixties and seventies there weren't a lot of good role models and I think
he was a pretty good role model.
And I think what I took,
you know he did an art Davey,
you know,
he did like an end run on the UFC and try to start something else while he was
underpaid.
You guys just call girls looks good.
Damn.
Look how thick these ring car girls were back to is that staging the Latina feed
these girls.
So yeah,
I'm holy Mackerel old old school man.
Look at the,
even that padding around the octagon.
Look at Leo still spry.
Look at the padding around the octagon yet.
It was actually the shipping material that we sent the octagon it and,
and then we just unwrapped it and use that again.
Look at
that with zip ties around.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
Holy Shit.
And then Ron van Cleef at 50 years old with a tie Mac behind him.
Who is the star of the last dragon?
No,
he,
it was like the next to the last dragon,
wasn't it?
No.
Is that he was the one where he played a Bruce Lee Roy member.
Yes,
I do remember.
And he was in some wacky MTV thing too.
Well he was a real athlete is a real martial artist.
Yeah.
But nothing ever happened to him after that.
He's like he did that movie the last dragon and then and then,
okay you,
you cut way ahead.
It's a um,
it's this,
you got to see the take down cause it happens like seconds in.
And this is what happens when,
you know a karate guy sleep during that.
Yeah.
Well they knew what this was about as close to a four far gone conclusion,
forgone conclusion.
How's that expression go?
Forgone as a,
you ever get a hoists was 27 years old and the prime of his life and he just
came out through a keg duct on there.
Look at that beautiful duck.
It started out with a front kick to measure distance and then came down with
that kick into the take down.
And that's a wrap.
I mean,
he just got ahold,
got ahold of Ron van Cleef,
and this is just academic from here on in.
Ron's not going to advance position.
He's never going to get out of side control legs,
voices just,
yeah,
he's just taking his time here.
He's waiting for Ron to relax or make a mistake or whatever.
And hoists was a master at that to master where they would call cooking guys
that you cook them,
hold them down and then once you got them down and you decide that you're going
to mount them,
you start sliding that left knee up.
He would get that left knee in between the space of the two legs.
Go back to it.
I'll get that off there.
What ad?
Who gives a shit show the fight.
Um,
so he,
he's got,
I'm holding down here and Ron van Cleef literally had no idea what to do.
He never thought he was going to be in this position.
He thought that,
why didn't he?
Because he's a karate master though.
He's like,
we brought emails.
Dot.
Hoists shouldn't matter it.
Look at it in the voice.
Slowly but surely it takes them back.
He slowly but surely use that left leg spun around and I was full mount
and then here Jim Brown.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
Here it goes.
He saved this in the Jim Brown
hydrate.
It totally works for tea.
Oh he was talking about hoist to at least,
uh,
losing the chemo.
That's what they're talking about.
Cause you remember that at a,
not losing the chemo but chemo and then then leaving the fight when he was
supposed to find out chemo came into that fight.
Yeah.
With a cross with Joe Sohn who turned out to be a gang rapists,
you know about all that of course.
But that cross,
you know,
that was not a display cross.
No fucking like hundred pound cross.
Yeah,
I'd probably worry,
wait at least a hundred pounds.
You know,
they brought that in in like four different,
these giant gym bags kind of like sewn together,
came in with I go,
dude,
what's up with that?
They go,
uh,
training equipment and back then no one even knew that he was going to come out
strapped to a cross.
No Man.
That's hilarious.
That's one of the all time classic things.
Amazing Chemo coming out.
Literally strapped to a big cross.
Yeah,
a giant wooden cross and then fought from there.
Now tell me what happened with Ron.
Ron Van Cleef come to your office.
Show Ron.
There's chemo,
it's an actual cross and chemo was up beast back then too.
Holy Shit.
That was a big boy.
Yeah.
So tell me what,
so Ron comes in and he comes in,
um,
I forget where he was,
maybe Philadelphia.
I don't think he was based in New York.
And he brings in a couple of his acolytes.
Who are these two?
How would you describe them there?
I'm very white looking guys
like Abercrombie and Fitch kind of models.
[inaudible]
Kinda twink ish.
I'm not saying that.
Okay.
I'm saying they're going to get it.
They're kind of cut and they're built,
but they don't look like fighters.
Okay.
They look kind of guy.
I'm not saying that and uh,
but Abercrombie fee,
you know,
you can,
can you,
you know what that looks like?
So there with him and he comes in and he says,
and they're standing behind him.
He's sitting at the chair in front of my,
you know,
my desk and they're standing behind him with her arms crossed doing this,
where it [inaudible] right.
And he goes,
I like to enter the UFC.
And I go,
I,
you know,
Ron,
I don't know,
man it,
and they go,
oh,
it's like they're growling at me in this weird.
Really?
Yeah.
They grounded,
it wasn't a grouse in what she was like,
uh,
oh,
watch your step.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know who you're talking to.
And um,
he and Iran goes,
we talk,
and then they're growling and he goes,
he goes,
I'm in really great shape.
And he pulls up his shirt and he's ripped,
you know,
he's 50,
but he's really ripped.
Right.
He's shredded,
you know,
he goes,
come over here and punch me in the stomach.
And like one,
let me tell you,
I have no interest in punching him in the stomach.
It's just like,
not what I want to do.
I have no desire.
There's no part of my brain goes,
go punch him.
Nothing.
I don't want to touch him.
I don't want to go,
you know,
and uh,
there,
and he's holding his shirt up and the guy started going,
this is an insult to my sensei.
This is a need.
This our son,
Shari is insulted.
And I don't know if I was insulting them cause I wouldn't punch him or cause I
was considering punching him.
I couldn't really tell from that.
And then we all in rockets [inaudible] calms down and we're saying,
well what do I have to do to get into the UFC?
I go,
yeah man,
I don't know man.
We're going a little bit of hot water here with the cock fighting thing and I
want to put your 50 year old Kochan and this is not gonna work out for me.
And I just don't,
I don't see any good coming from this.
And he goes,
well,
I'm going to run the marathon.
I said,
well,
if you can do that,
maybe you come back.
And when I said come back like the man behind the curtain in the wizard of Oz,
you know,
the great and powerful.
Then the guy started in again with [inaudible] say,
you know,
and I wanted that point to go,
fuck are you and what are you guys doing here?
What are you the three stooges?
And he's,
you know,
Mo,
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't get the dynamic and,
but then he agreed to run the marathon in two hours and 49 million or whatever
the time was.
It was like a real time and the name.
Oh.
Then they want it to take their shirts off.
And that's what I found very bizarre.
Like I'm the only one in my office with a shirt on.
So they took their shirts off as well.
Shirts came off.
So Ron van Cleef has his shirt off this two A's more holding it up.
So he's holding his shirt up.
The errors are Fitch guys take their shirts off.
Why did they take their shirts off?
I,
you know,
I don't know.
Maybe they thought I was,
some fucking was going to go down.
I don't know if that's how they roll.
Pull the shades down and we're all done.
You know,
I should've taken my shirt off.
He should have those.
Yeah.
Maybe by taking your pants off.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just fucking cut to the chase.
What are we trying to do dude?
What's up with this?
So,
um,
what happened after that?
He did,
he did the marathon,
he came back and you know,
we put him in and you know,
he was a,
he was a decorated veteran from Vietnam.
Right.
And he was a legend in the black martial arts world,
the African American martial arts world and the white martial arts world.
He was a legend.
He was very well known.
Yeah.
He was definitely well known,
but he was a,
he was revered in the African American,
you know,
a martial arts world.
And uh,
so that was good.
You know,
we were always trying to broaden the audience and we,
you know,
look pretty white at some points in the UFC history.
So it was nice to have him represent Bruce Lee there.
He is a guy,
you know,
at least sparred,
fought with Bruce Lee.
That's kind of cool.
Yeah,
no,
it's very cool.
Well he's,
the guy had mad balls,
you know,
he's still competes to this city.
Did have mad balls.
I,
you know,
it's like 50 years old and you come into the UFC,
he didn't know he was going to get voice.
He could've got chemo,
he could've got tank.
Yeah.
Oh Jesus.
You know what?
Actually I gotta to say this cause I'm making fun of him.
So I want to tell the other side of this.
So we made him the commissioner and there was a point,
it must've been,
he was fighting and four maybe it was five or six and tank.
We were in Wyoming tanks backstage,
like looking to pick a fight backstage,
you know,
who goes to a fight to pick a fight,
please walking around looking for a fight that yeah,
he,
because tank was,
you know,
tank was all mental,
everyone thinks,
you know,
he was just giant wide guy,
benched 600 wrestled at B B.
Why you buy it with those guys?
You know,
he was a tough,
tough guy,
but he was mental fucked with everyone from the moment he showed up.
She's walking around and I said to the state trooper,
I go,
can you kind of,
cause we had state troopers doing security backstage and they're in their full
on state trooper gear.
Right.
You know,
with the boots and the hat and a smokey thing.
And uh,
the state trooper looks at me.
He goes,
sir,
the only thing I could do to that man would be to shoot him.
Don't shoot him.
That's it.
So anyway,
uh,
tank was acting up and Ron van Cleef went over and kind of button hold him and
said,
I don't know what he said.
Said he said,
settle the fuck down,
son and tank did.
And I don't know why.
Cause you know,
Ron was a chin high to tank and probably tank outweighed him by 150 pounds.
Tank was embarrassed,
you know,
just maybe she was just being silly and drunk.
Maybe.
Was tank fighting or was he,
was he just partied partying?
Uh,
I think it was the one before we introduced him.
Oh,
well that makes sense.
Yeah.
So he was back there like making himself,
well,
tank was a very interesting,
uh,
chapter in MMA,
in my opinion,
an important chapter.
And she was the Ronda Rousey of,
uh,
of our day.
You know,
I wouldn't say that I would,
he's very,
very different.
I'd say tank Abbott.
I wouldn't ever say he was a Rhonda Rousey or anything.
I mean,
he didn't have the credentials that Rhonda has.
He wasn't as skillful or a champion.
He was,
was a guy who could talk mad shit and he would fight anybody.
He was fighting,
fight anybody.
You can call tank Abbott the night before.
He could be out drinking and it could be Sunday morning and he was fighting
someone when called,
he is currently fighting,
you know,
tank stop fighting him and come fight.
This is the real deal.
I mean,
it wasn't just a character in a movie.
He really was.
That guy did like Ron van Cleef.
He would step up,
here's why.
He was like,
Rhonda,
you're exactly right.
You're 100% right.
You're always right.
Here's the different,
here's the different cases.
Fuck that.
That's a little late in the game for tank though,
isn't it?
That was UFC tank wasn't even UFC tank.
He was never lean.
Not Eliminating is just a powerhouse.
But tank brought an excitement and a new fan into the sport the way Rhonda has.
And I think it was an important development for the UFC to have,
you know,
an all American bad guy,
a guy that represented the every man,
you know,
the Yahoo Ism,
and he was a pretty skilled fighter,
you know,
he did have skills and he was toughest,
couldn't be tougher.
And so I think he really opened it up beyond the geeky world,
you know,
the martial arts world and gave us a bunch of fans that weren't martial arts
fans.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
You know,
and yeah,
there's very important staff.
There was certainly something in and he also knew how to,
and he was a media favorite,
you know,
here right before he gets into the cage.
Is that silver behind,
can't see is that before he goes into the octagon he's having a beard.
Might be after.
I think it's,
I think that's during,
it might be before he's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Yes.
Uh,
but he uh,
he had some serious fucking power though.
That's one thing tanks had.
He was massive knock guys dead by punching power.
He know what a punch he could knock guys dead and with those gloves and while he
was on one of the first guys to wear them,
I think he was the first,
was he,
it was either him or no art Jimmerson war the one of course,
right?
Yeah,
I think it was,
I think you're right.
I think tank was the first guy and then a veto or came around and warm for his
debut as well.
And that what but Vito was 12,
12.
Yeah.
And tank was six.
Somewhere around there.
Right?
Yeah.
Tank versus now.
Mark.
Steve,
no,
mark.
To this day,
one of the greatest Kaos and the history of the sport,
one of the most brutal.
And then John Matula,
the first one on another unbelievable Kao.
You know,
John [inaudible] is who wrote a apocalypse now wrote,
I love the smell of napalm in the morning,
right?
Wrote the dirty Harry movies,
directed the cone in the movies.
Uh,
and you know,
it was really a creative force in the early days of the UFC.
He goes,
you can't let the big guys lose.
And you know,
it's hard to tell John Milless he's wrong.
You know,
I didn't want to tell
me is wrong,
but he was wrong because I think when Manny Arbor or lost twin Matua lost when
Paul Vera Lynn's,
you know,
the,
the polar bear windows big guys lose.
It's real.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Everybody's got to lose,
man.
That's,
that's the thing.
It's like,
and also guys who you don't think you're gonna lose,
have to lose.
That's still a wild watching tank.
Right?
That clinic that's like tank row.
Thank you.
Throw some fucking leather.
A Dude could bang and he find anybody.
I really respected that,
that he would just fight anybody at the drop of a hat if I Pedro his own Brazil,
you know,
as you say,
will fight anyone.
Yeah.
And it had a lot of fun fights.
He had a lot of fun fights inside the octagon and then came back and fought in
the UFC back in the early two thousands when the UFC was a struggling tank.
Abbott was one of their,
uh,
things that they introduced,
like Dana White introduced him into the octagon,
brought him in there and start talking shit again and he's a great mistake.
Yeah.
You know,
he had the act down.
It was good.
Yeah.
And he had a whole bunch of guys that he would,
uh,
you know,
Eddie Sanchez,
a bunch of guys who trained with man.
It was tough.
We used to say there was like the three stooges on the dangerous.
They were dangerous.
They were like,
uh,
it was like a small riot following tank through the,
you know,
and I guess
there was none of that.
You know,
I did like when tank took the pin,
there was posters of Ken shamrock and tank found big vaginas from penthouse for
any glued the vagina's very carefully over Ken speedos and then hung those up.
But uh,
that's a nice touch.
Yeah.
Look at that.
That's mature,
right?
No,
I don't think this one's meant to us.
I think that's Paul Violins.
It's hard to tell who's he got down there.
It's hard to tell who he's fighting.
But tank did that,
he did that to Steven Elmore now marquee knocked out.
Oh,
that's all I tech tar off.
That was a great guy.
Oh,
like,
and then,
yeah,
you could hit that guy with a brick.
I don't think it did anything.
Yeah.
And all like again,
well,
hens on knocked him out with a fucking upkick.
Remember that?
That was in like the world combat league.
I think he was trying to throw somebody out of the octagon once.
That wasn't Bella Tori.
No,
he was,
uh,
he,
he uh,
he knocked him out with an upkick.
It might've been in Brazil,
I forget where it was,
but old leg was standing over him.
And Henzel up kicked him and k Odom and old like fell back and he was out cold
and then hands off followed it up with the right hand.
But he was already out cold.
He was alcohol from the UPC.
Keck.
That's another thing that I think if I could change anything,
I would allow the guy on the bottom to,
to a strike on the ground,
like to kick to the face on the ground.
Even if the guy's on his knees and you should be able to knee and kick a guy in
the face on the ground.
Cause you can't kick a guy.
You can't up kick a guy if a guy has one knee down.
I think that's ridiculous.
I think if you're on your back,
the guy should be able to kick you.
I mean if you're on your back,
you should be able to kick the guy in the face period.
If a guy's on his knee,
if the guys at anywhere,
you know the guy is,
if he's above you and you're on your back,
you should be able to kick him in the face.
The fact that you can't,
it's silly.
The,
um,
the only reason why I think you shouldn't be able to kick a guy on the ground is
soccer kicks if a guy's head is near the cage,
because if you're near the cage and your head is pinned up,
you're going to stomp you are soccer kick you and you can't get out of the way.
But one of the interesting things about pride was the stomps into the soccer
kicks.
I mean,
that was,
that was an interesting aspect of it.
Those were effective techniques.
It's hard to say that,
you know,
it's hard to say that those are any more or less brutal than regular head kicks
there.
Basically.
It's the same.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But I tell you what I do know is with pride,
you know,
in early days UFC,
the visualness was very important that people saw it was very different.
I'm not sure that's as important now with the UFC.
You in fact,
you almost want it to be like something you recognize when you turn it on.
It's not that people want to predictability,
but I think they want to feel like they might be able to understand the matchups
enough to pick who's going to win.
You know?
And I think the more outrageous techniques add to that outrageous visual appeal.
And you know,
I'm not sure that's,
it's not,
you know,
Joe,
is it right to say you think is close to a real fight is what it should be.
Yes.
Yeah.
As close to a real fight as you can get,
which is why I don't like stand ups and I know people say,
well was going to make it boring and it killed the sport.
I don't believe that.
I think you're gonna have more guys like Hanan Barao more guys that you can't
take down.
And if you do take them down,
you know they're gonna fucking submit you.
You know,
Charles Olivera in his last fight caught a guy with a,
a belief it's a triangle off of his back in the same sort of situation.
That guy was trying to hold them down,
trying to,
guy was trying to beat him.
Guy took him down,
held onto him and his guard and he got submitted and that's how it should be a
guy.
If you'd take a guy down,
that guy had better get good at one or two things,
either you better get good at submitting guys or better get,
get good at getting back up to his feet or sweeping one of the other.
You have to get good at those things.
If you're not good at those things,
well then guys should take you down and they should hold you down and that's
real.
If as soon as you like instigate these standups,
you're,
you're putting something into a,
you initiate a stand up,
you're putting something into a fight that's not natural.
I don't,
I don't like standups.
I don't like guys who use time on the ground to recoup.
I don't either.
But if you can,
why not?
No,
no,
that's exactly right.
Well,
look at what happened with the best guys are not going to do that again.
I hate to use these two guys in example,
but you don't see that with Josie Aldo.
You don't see Josie all,
they'll take guys down and hold on to them.
You don't see Hanan Barao take guys down and hold on to them and just take
their,
catch their breath.
GSP do it a little bit.
He did it.
He definitely did it.
No,
and I love GSPs the greatest.
I think GSP is a very intelligent fighter and part of being a very intelligent
fighters.
You fight saves what you can.
Yeah.
You could criticize him for that.
You like,
and I understand it,
I get it.
But it took a guy like Johnny Hendricks who was trying to murder GSP to,
you know,
to drag d GSP into the deepest water that he's ever been in,
in his career,
in,
in as a champion to master.
It should be those duck dynasty guys.
That's not right.
Wrapped it.
Fucking get a good handle on that.
Just give them a beaten.
Um,
but with your teeth,
well you can't grab hair.
So I would guess,
no.
I guess if a guy,
he have a big,
nobody has had one of those beers came into the octagon.
They've had a decent one was,
I think it was patting some of the punches.
It was like,
Ah,
who says that?
People do say that?
Like it was nothing.
It's ridiculous.
That's the thing in boxing though,
right?
You're supposed to,
it was more so that your skin wouldn't cut.
Was that what it was?
I think that's what that is.
I don't think anyone thinks.
What about Alex Caceres?
He has this gigantic huge Afro.
I mean,
should that be able to protect him against,
uh,
against head kicks?
I mean,
is that,
is that cushioning,
that giant Afro?
It's bad ass.
If I had that kind of hair,
I'd wear an Afro because Sarah's absolutely.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think there's a few rules that could be changed.
I think a big one for me is the 12 six elbow.
I think that's a ridiculous rule to get to the purity of fighting.
As soon as that's your mantra.
That's what I'm talking about.
And that's a shorter version than I,
he got to be.
I just remember it gets bigger.
He's got a bigger one now.
That's a,
he had a huge victory recently over Sergio Pettis.
Did you see that?
No,
I did not.
Great.
Great fucking fight.
Ooh,
very exciting.
So much new talent.
You have seen so many fights and you're still,
you love everyone.
Oh,
no question.
You're unbelievable.
Well,
I'm just fortunate that I'm a real fan,
you know,
it's not like a job for me.
I know.
I mean it certainly is a job for me.
I take it very serious and professional.
Like people always say like,
Oh do you do the UFC stone?
Like that's a big question that I get all the time cause I do a lot of things
high obviously.
Um,
why is that?
I've never,
I tell people I'm never,
I don't never,
don't do it at all.
Don't think about doing it.
It's not necessary.
It's not,
it wouldn't be helpful to you.
Hi.
Cause me on it.
No.
If that was you.
Hi.
Are the real problems and I'd have to,
yeah,
I would,
I would really have problems.
Like marijuana turned out to be a very good medicinal drug for me just for life.
You know,
people say like,
what do you,
what do you take medical marijuana for life.
I need it for life.
I got a condition.
The condition is called the real world.
It's called camp though.
You know,
real life life is fucking crazy.
But my,
my fortune in being,
working for the UFC is a,
I don't have to pretend to like it.
I don't pretend like this.
There's guys who cover basketball.
They don't give a flying fuck about basketball.
You see it.
I don't want it to be sports guys.
I never wanted to be a sports guy.
So Dana in pushing me and you guys in hiring me first and then Dana and pushing
me to become a commentator made me do it.
You know,
if it wasn't for that,
I would have just probably be talking about at the same way.
I just wouldn't,
I remember you at 11 your eyes were like this big gay were,
you were,
so you were,
you were a kid at Christmas.
You really were,
was 12 yeah,
UFC 12 yeah.
Yeah.
I was,
I was a law.
No,
but it was 1997 Dothan,
Alabama.
Yeah.
Doesn't the peanut capital of the world.
I certainly,
uh,
had a great fucking time.
But I think that what the difference in today is there's,
there's a bunch of differences and the difference in today is that what you're
seeing and when you watch these guys fight is true.
Worldclass absolutely.
That's what's been the most amazing thing is watching that transition from MMA
fighters that some of them were elite,
like Vito was elite even at 19.
And when Vito or fought Scott for Ozo and trade telecom and trade telling man
first of all,
that that was the first time we ever got to see him.
I had seen him before because I was training at Vituro school with Vito was
training across some Gracie's.
So I got to see him train there and I also got to see his first fight with John
Hess,
which was in,
um,
in Hawaii and eve.
Oh,
looked up John Hess.
I mean,
just lit him up like a Christmas tree.
So I knew what kind of speed and power he had at a striking,
but that was,
he was one of the first real true world class athletes.
How crazy.
Yes.
I think Ken shamrock.
Oh yes.
Ken shamrock was a really tough guy.
More than tough guy.
Football player.
Very accomplished athletes.
Pat Smith,
good kickboxer Vito Rodeo.
Vito was on another level.
If Vittorio was,
I know,
but you know it's not exactly right that there,
there,
there were some guys in the beginning,
you know,
I mean,
Gordo was a professional fighter.
you know,
he would do okay in kickboxing today,
but he would not know.
I don't think so.
He would do okay.
You would do okay but not like v tour.
Vito was the first guy that to me had that,
that real elite athlete ability like pull up v tour versus um,
Trey telling them trays,
Tra telling man,
um,
v toward to me was the first guy that showed like modern martial arts skills.
Like if you watched what he did there,
you could see a guy do that in this UFC.
I know it's hard to,
it's hard to argue that because it has a physical specimen freak.
Well,
it's weird is he's just as good now.
He must have been.
How old was he when teams,
yeah,
he was 19 I think I met him before he was Nike.
I think he just turned 18 when I met him.
Not when he fought,
when he fought.
He was 19 when he fought in the UFC rather he was 19 baby.
Yeah,
look at him.
That's a,
that's the first v tour and everybody knew him as a Jujitsu black belt.
That's what everybody means.
Great.
Using the name Victor Gracie.
It was victor too is the VI K Tor.
They spelled it differently and then they went with v tour after that.
Like when I was interviewing him and talking backstage,
I even called him Victor Gracie at one point in time,
like inadvertently,
but they were all in the middle of something with Horian were Horian was keeping
him from using the Gracie name and uh,
they,
they also changed it from Victor To v tour and I don't know why they were
calling him victor in the first place.
I don't know if they were trying to Americanize him or what,
but no one knew what to expect from Vituro.
Vidor is less American.
Yes,
it was.
What,
say Victor,
why they were calling him victor?
I think they were trying to Americanize it,
but Vic victor at the time,
which we used to all call him,
uh,
he came out like this and no one knew that he was this elite Stryker.
I mean he just unloads on trade telling man and he was fast.
Oh,
he's fast.
And he was a great grappler and everybody expected this.
They expected a take down attempt,
but he clinched with them and instigated these insane striking fucking
exchanges.
Joe Fifth Years.
So flash forward 15 years,
I don't think who Vidor I don't think he's had the career he should have had.
Um,
maybe,
maybe he went through some tough times and you've got to give him a little bit
of slack because of what happened to his sister.
Horrific,
horrific story.
She was murdered,
raped,
and murdered.
And it's just horrifying.
And then the,
there was the breakup,
the split up between him and crossing Gracie.
He went through some periods of his life where he had some serious issues and
was,
was losing and fights in Japan.
You know that you just didn't look like this guy when he fought.
Sakharova just never looked like this guy.
Randy coture stole a little bit of its soul.
That's,
that's a fact.
Randy coture when he beat v or the first time he took a little bit of
[inaudible] soul that was,
uh,
back when Vituro was young and wild and very young.
He had all these good things going for him,
but he couldn't deal with that.
Captain America pressure.
I'm forgetting.
I'm on your show again.
I'm like,
tell me more about it.
Let's talk more about,
I want to hear more about Randy events cause he's rack.
Randy was a very experienced fighter and a great athlete and he knew how to win.
That's the thing about those wrestlers is they know how to win.
They know how to suck it up and they know how to suck it up.
They know how to deal with adversity because they dealt with it every day in the
training room.
Get the ears.
Yeah.
The d,
the amount of diversity you have to deal with to be an elite amateur wrestler is
unparalleled in the world of sports because it's not just hard training.
It's hard training where you're going to war with other men on a daily basis
with every fucking ounce of your energy in every,
every last drop manifests.
It's about men,
a big part of it and you know,
you almost couldn't do boxing that much and you can't do on the mat now you
can't because you get fucking brain damage of the hospital.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you boxed all day,
just constantly boxed all day,
just got your fucking head rattled in all day saying what you jets,
you can do that.
Exactly.
Well,
that's one of the things that I really love about Jujitsu is that you can do it
and you can train hard and still not get injured.
The real problem with Jujitsu is just the wear and tear on the body over years
and years of doing it.
If you do like an hour and a half,
two hours of like hard you do to everyday things is blow out.
Right.
Exactly.
Well,
you can a little bit and you get better at rolling lightly and technically,
but bad shit still happens to the best guys I know.
The elite of the elite,
they blow their knees out,
they twist their ankles,
they hurt their,
you know,
you make me love the UFC more and I never didn't love it.
No.
You,
uh,
that was one of the cool things about you being,
you know,
at the helm.
I think Meyrowitz was more of a guy who was in it for the business of it.
Maybe enjoyed it while it was happening to the first one.
First one was it bull shit.
They probably thought it was going to fucking go crazy.
People are going to die.
There's veto versus John Hess.
This is Vito at like,
look at that.
Look at fun.
She played that from the beginning.
And John Hassell was a guy who poked guys in the eye and shit.
He,
uh,
he had,
I forget.
And the,
I forget the dude's name that he fought.
Isn't there a beginning of this video just says that.
Oh,
it just has that dude that is fucking ridiculous.
He had some serious hand speed and still does.
That's what's great.
I mean,
this looks really good.
Well,
he's the next guy fighting for the title 36.
Yeah.
Something along those lines.
He's fighting for the fucking title.
He's going to fight.
He's going to fight Chris Weidman [inaudible] Vegas in Vegas,
and it becomes a real issue because of testosterone replacement.
He has an exemption that he uses for testosterone replacement.
Wait a minute back that up lacks aliens.
Oh,
okay.
That's Henry host the,
uh,
that's,
that guy's done.
Ray Lewis is down there training with them.
Henry,
who has done a tremendous job with their,
their striking and he's a,
uh,
he's certainly a part of the resurgence of,
of veto or along with that whole Blackzilians camp.
But the real issue is testosterone replacement,
you know,
veto or uses testosterone.
And he has a doctor's exemption in Brazil,
but he can't get one in Vegas and or neither can I be,
if you just want to go on record,
they won't give me the fee and can't get one.
And He,
maybe he can get one in Vegas,
but I'm saying is it's being,
it's not just automatically being offered up to them.
And one of the reasons for that is that he tested positive for steroids in the
past.
And that's the big argument is that if you did test positive for steroids in the
past and they can prove that,
then you shouldn't be able to get testosterone because the reason why your
testosterone is low in the first place is because you cheated.
So it gets real weird method does,
it gets real weird,
but the results,
Holy Shit.
Who's a better fucking poster boy for Testosterone Replacement Than v tour?
Because at 37 no,
not even close at 37 or 36 years of age vittores still worldclass whereas Ken,
I'm an admirer,
Ken Shamrock,
he's a great fighter and had some great,
really underrated fights in pride.
You know?
You know what?
That's a great point because he had some very tough fights in pride.
He's a tough fighter.
He's a tough bastard and he is a tough,
been around a long time and he had really good leg locks too back in the day
when no one knew and nobody liked lock was when he fought in the UFC and he'll
hooked his first guy and ripped his fucking nia part.
Who was that guy that he uh,
he,
he'll hooked.
And one of the first UFC,
he's,
oh,
was it a well,
the kickbox that you were talking about earlier,
Pat Smith,
didn't he heal?
Look Pat Smith and fuck his knee up.
I believe he did.
Ken shamrock versus Cat Smith's so much about this deal hooked him and ripped
his knee apart.
I remember Pat Smith screaming like,
Ken shamrock just tears fucking me up.
Absolutely.
I can now.
Now I see pat going,
I remember him going,
yeah.
You know,
he couldn't tap fast.
10 shamrock Pat Smith can take what was a great,
we'll end with this.
Yeah.
Ken was,
Ken's very underrated,
very underrated.
But you know,
he's a guy who we rapping.
We're three hours in,
but we did three hours already.
You kidding?
Oh,
flew by.
Who's?
Listen to me for,
they'll listen to you wish plugged my Twitter again.
Can coupling calm Bhate Campo combat day and it's a,
the show is a combatant,
the Americas.
And when is it again?
It's this Sunday,
but we're doing a Sunday at 10 o'clock.
But uh,
your,
your fans might want to check out Gringo Wednesdays,
Wednesdays at 10 o'clock with the English subtitles.
You're going to love the show.
You'd be amended to show next season.
Joe,
you do with them on,
what do you want me to do?
I don't know if I can talk.
I mean it might not be able to contractually do it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
And he said,
okay,
we'll see if he does.
I asked him to give me all this money.
You know what,
if you are allowed,
we would love to have you.
You can come on plug a plug the UFC.
Well,
if I'm around and I can,
I will definitely do.
I think it'd be fun,
but I'll definitely watch it.
I'm going to set my DVR.
Please do check it out.
I'd love to and uh,
I wish you luck.
I mean,
you're a great guy.
If it wasn't for you,
I would've never worked for the UFC.
So I think it is true.
It is man.
You're the door.
The UFC has benefit.
You're the door that got me in and uh,
from there it's a,
it's been a lot of fun.
So,
uh,
I thank you you,
and I thank you for almost getting me a fight with Wesley snipes.
That was kind of fun too.
It was fun.
It made me realize how hard it is to train to fight that.
That was a life changing three months.
Cool.
Made me exhausted every day of falling asleep,
sitting in front of the TV conking out every night.
It was so fucking tired.
Just training twice a day.
Just on Howard.
Cause you went on a long time ago.
No,
no,
no.
When you,
when you were talking about the fight,
what,
where were we in the process at that point where you're tired of waiting on me
to get Wesley to agree or I don't think that was on Howard Stern.
Yeah,
no,
that's where it first came out.
You went on Howard and talked about it.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause Jeff,
your manager calls me,
I think gave me a heads up that he's talking about it.
I don't remember.
That seems wrong though.
Trying to figure that out.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't remember.
There's a long time ago,
but um,
how many years ago was that?
Like 2007 or something like that.
When did the last night of Bingo
for that?
Cause I was just before I did the iron ring.
Yeah,
it's about that time.
2006,
2007.
Yeah.
Um,
that was,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
Cool.
Would that have been,
it would have been cool for what had been very cool as long as it took,
as long as it took,
it would have been interesting.
I,
I don't not like that guy.
Just want everybody to know I'm a,
I'm a big fan of that guy.
No,
you never had a grudge against blade.
Just thought it was cool.
He's a great actor.
He's a cool actor.
He's been in a lot of cool moves.
Here's Ken shamrock
and that's it.
Yeah.
And Pat Smith,
Pat Smith tried to kick him.
He tried to kick them on the ground and Ken got ahold of that.
He'll,
pat didn't know how to escape.
That was not even an,
that's there's some space in there too.
These days.
Guys would step over with that left leg and spin out of it or try to push on the
bus and try to get their foot out.
But Pat didn't know what he's doing on his back or,
yeah,
he's trying to elbow and screaming and just,
his knees was ripped apart.
Look and pass land there.
And Ken,
Ken's man dog,
and I'm now,
the guy's screaming.
That shit hurts so bad because when with a a heel hook,
your meniscus just gets ripped apart.
It just gets snapped and crackled and popped.
It's a terrible feeling to pat was the first African American,
uh,
Rodeo champion.
Was He really a really good athlete or Rodeo champion?
Did he ride bulls?
Are your horses or would he ride the fuck?
Do I know [inaudible] something with legs?
I don't know.
I didn't know about the,
I know less about the Rodeo than I do about,
I don't know.
You gotta be a tough fuck Rodeo trained to be a black cowboys.
A tough Gig to yeah,
indeed.
But probably how you learn how to kickbox
Campbell,
Mclaren Campbell combating on Twitter.
Follow him on Twitter.
That's c a m P,
B e l l,
c o m.
B a,
t e
Campbell combat day and watch combined day Americana's let's say right.
Commodity America,
America combined two Americas.
Just looking forward on your,
uh,
your,
your local guide and uh,
it's probably on more than once a week,
right?
It's on five times a week.
Wednesdays Green.
Yeah.
Speaking of being on TV,
my episode,
uh,
me and Brian Cowen,
we're on meat eater and it airs.
Tomorrow night we'd go hunting for white tail deer.
And a in Wisconsin is a two part episode this week and next week.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
it's on the sportsmans channel,
so go check that out.
Thanks to our sponsors,
lumosity.com.
Go to lumosity.com and use a lumosity.com.
Forward Slash Joe,
go there and click start training and play your first game.
Booch and thanks also to,
what else is it today?
audible.com audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe get a free audio
book and 30 free days of audible service,
the number one source of audio entertainment on the internets.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t use the code word Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements supplements.
That's just like supplements but from a mush mouth motherfucker like me and we
will be back tomorrow night with a dot tomorrow day with Doctor Rhonda Patrick.
Doctor Rhonda Patrick is a a a an expert in nutrition and vitamins and she's
going to tell us a lot about what is and what is not effective.
What has been scientifically proven about vitamins,
uh,
should be very interesting because there's a lot of like misinformation and
confusion and studies and counter study.
So we're going to try to like spell it all out and get to the meat of
everything.
Campbell Mclaren,
you're a bad motherfucker.
I love you.
Thanks for doing this.
Thanks a lot of fun.
The people online enjoyed it and they will follow you at Campbell.
Come Bhate on Twitter tonight.
We will be at the Ice House Comedy Club in Pasedena.
Not that many tickets still available.
Duncan Trussell,
Ari Shaffir,
Justin Martin del Brian Red Band,
and Tony Hische,
cliff and me.
All right,
we'll see you soon.
We love the fuck out of Ya.
Bye Bye.